[Music]
it's looking really ominous especially
given that he's down on time
this is the magnus carlson squeeze um
wow hicaro's playing in front of
hundreds of people imagine
being in his shoes right now i mean up
by four games
well i can resign yeah carl knows it it
started with 16 players and
it all came down to one man magnus
carlson
[Music]
this is a pretty great matchup i know
people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's
the beast an absolute monster
it has been hecaro's speech his
championship this 2018 hiker nakamura
the overall 1c takes it home
in the speeches championship
[Music]
obviously this is a rematch of last
year's scc final what a finish by the
way i mean that's been the story of the
match the kara nakamura has just kind of
out swindled out tricked and out
calculated wesley in the critical moment
up dude that's a nice move wesley's
shaking his head
ikaro wins upon he's going to draw this
game i can't believe it which
happened unbelievable hey karo nakamura
holding that position he had no business
drawing that game
[Music]
and we are back with another match in
the 2020 speed chess championship
alongside me
the man who you can't spell chess
without robert hess is back
it's been too long buddy you know
honestly
a single day is too long not
commentating with you i missed you man
no i mean i feel like this is one of
those things where absence makes the
heart grow fonder and all of a sudden we
realize how much we enjoy working
together it's been too many man
no i'm kidding i love how we play the uh
you know the awkward tension role but
seriously we're gonna have a great day
today you and i get to cover a match
that we know
is a literal coin flip i think
i i mean everybody might might have
their favorite and and could argue
different reasons but
don napomnishi versus lavonna brony and
one of the ones you and i had circled
and uh i can't wait to see what we have
in store today
yeah absolutely it's one of those
matches where if you hear it's
the final round of the candidates
playing for a chance for the world title
you wouldn't be surprised but these two
are going head-to-head they're clashing
online
and both are worthy competitors i mean
we've seen these players year after year
in the speedchest championship
and i feel like jan de palmashi he's
hungry these days
but levon aronian always the steady hand
when it comes to chess so
i do think this is a toss-up these two
guys met up a couple years ago we
remember a match that came down to the
wire
so we'll see if that happens yet again
let's remind everybody of
what the format is and what that would
look like if we came down to the wire
as we always do at the stop sorry at the
top
of the of the show at the stop of the
show the stop of the show would be we we
drop the mics and walk out no at the top
of the show
remind you of the format it's a single
elimination knockout
the 2020 speeches championship is the
same format we've been doing here for a
few years
90 minutes of five minutes 16 minutes of
three and 30 minutes of one minute with
the one second increment the great
equalizer as we call it
throughout if a match is tied we will
have a four game mini match of bullet we
have had one match go to overtime this
year if you missed
the alireza ferrugia versus vladimir
putin save match that is a worthy
back back your thing up and go check out
that match was one of one of the
most exciting thrilling things we've had
in a long time uh so but
the players are also playing for a lot
robert we've doubled the prizes this
year
and uh every game as you know is still
worth money regardless of what the final
match score is
and it could be should be fun to see a
couple of guys here who they've been
playing this thing since it was the
measly thirty thousand dollars we
started with back in 2016 me and you
buddy
now they get a hundred thousand dollars
it is amazing to see the first round
match-ups have more prize money than the
whole thing from back in the day
and i honestly have forgotten that it is
only round one
because how much excitement there has
been the fedocea ferrugia match
that was one of the most exciting
matches of all time no matter the format
no matter who was playing that was
excellent
and lavon and jan in the first round
this is just
as exciting as it gets absolutely and
uh we want to remind everybody it's also
super exciting
play guess the move we have cash prizes
being given out
every single time we have a speed chess
championship match
and uh you you can throw your hat in the
ring if you're a premium member you are
automatically eligible for cash prizes
just for doing something that's good for
your chess
and if you're not a premium member we're
giving away premium memberships
pretty much like participation trophies
you um we're like the oprah of premium
memberships you get a premium you get a
premium
as long as you're playing guess the move
so uh robert as we look at the bracket
here you and i are about to dive into
what we know is going to be a thrilling
match
um you've uh you covered the maxine
bache of the grav victory over niihau
sauron with me
all the way back on november 1st when we
kick things off you've been watching the
last few matches
uh what are your thoughts so far on what
you've seen and um
you know maybe not a bold prediction but
um
maybe you can predict who mvl would
rather face really in terms of the chess
um of yon napomnishi and levon aronian
right because mbl and levon are very
close friends he said as much that he's
always rooting for levon but he knows
that a match-up
against yon nepamshi is what many people
would love to see
because those two are at atop the
leaderboard in the postponed candidates
tournament right after seven rounds
those two players find themselves in
first place so i do think
just building up that tense potential
rivalry will be excellent
but as our smarter chess predictions
have shown this
is a toss-up a slight nod to yonda
pomneshi
based on really the quicker time patrols
but danny you know how i feel about
smart chess predictions
what do you think i know how you feel
and i know how we both feel when somehow
no matter how a match starts out it
almost always ends up being more
accurate than we would like to admit at
the end although the uh the ferugia fedo
say of match
not so not so much um and uh
well regardless yeah i mean i tend to
look at that and do
do kind of agree right i guess if we're
we're looking at yon napomnishi's
pedigree here you highlighted that he is
currently leading the candidates at the
break
with uh who would be his opponent in the
quarterfinals maxine bashilagrov
um but he's also just i think he's just
more well known in the online chess
community he's also a streamer
for those who uh who don't know you can
go to twitch.tv slash
luscious sq the name you see right there
it's the same as this just.com username
obviously he's not streaming today as
that is strictly forbidden there's this
is there is no banter blitz here this
is fully focused chess players and so we
do not allow the players to stream when
they're in the sec
but um but go give them a follow anyway
and i don't know if i if i look at it i
just i think that maybe it's
what have you done for me lately robert
and that of course i think of jan is a
better bullet player because he plays
more
so maybe that'll maybe that'll catch up
with us but i do see him as maybe the
slight nod in the fastest portion and
probably why i would see him with a
slight nod over levon aronian
as we take a look now at the armenia
number one and levon's bullet rating is
actually only three rating points
lower than uh yawns which is surprising
to me
but i think part of this is that lavon
is not a frequent player
in online chess right jan is playing all
the time hikaru farouza fedocev
and via all these guys are regularly
online perhaps
spent too much of their time online but
lavon he's one of those players who
shies away
from the online formats for the most
part unless he's playing on anonymous
accounts
so or anonymously playing bug house but
go ahead yeah
see he seems like you know more than i
do but danny what i was going to say is
that the
extra time the increment should be very
useful to a player like lavon
who may not have the mouse speed as some
of the others yep
no 100 obviously we'll talk about that
as it goes and it's something we we
always
have to draw our attention to because it
i always say keeps the x's and o's on
the board
just as much just as important
regardless of how fast the time control
gets
um and uh all right well we're gonna be
diving in here we'll see the players on
camera in just a second but let's remind
everybody that after this tomorrow you
and i will have the call
when the number one player in the event
makes his debut hikaru nakamura
the overall top seed defending champion
and number one as far as fide blitz goes
he'll be playing against hike marty
rosian so this is the first time in our
schedule here
of the round of 16 when we've had
back-to-back days so make sure you make
note of that
sometimes you watch an scc and you
figure you've got a few days to rest no
no not this week we have got a lot going
on so make sure you already mark your
calendar and join us tomorrow
and okay as we uh bring up the players
now we uh
we we did have yawn just a second ago we
still have lavon
um and uh we're about t minus
60 seconds a little more than that 75
seconds away from the first game getting
started so
last thoughts robert before we are taken
away into the world of scc
entertainment i hope john's getting paid
from whatever
company that shares from that's my first
thought like he
leaves as soon as we cut to him and
that's a pretty nice looking chair but
if you want my honest
chest related thoughts i really think it
depends which yonder palmistry we see
today
down at his best can go toe-to-toe with
even magnus carlsen when he's tilting a
bit and he
certainly is one of the players who
could suffer from that he can lose
four games in a row and against levon
aronian the armenian maestro
that's a dangerous place to be no you're
right and that's something we didn't
highlight in all the previews we went
through the smarter chess prediction
these guys have played before but you're
right i guess of the two players if you
had to pick somebody
who might be more likely to go on tilt
right we see it happen right hikaru
nakamura was active in the chat when
wesley so played his match just a few
days ago
and even wesley had some moments there
where we were like okay is wesley going
until right
and you were wondering and so if you had
to pick one of these players who might
need to get a control
control over their emotions it probably
would be yawn right just because of his
personality and and we've seen him
you know maybe struggle in those in
those moments some moments like that
in the past so all right well um
we are we are going to have liftoff here
any second
it is exactly time to begin 9 a.m
on the pacific west coast and uh here we
go
the games have begun we're going to have
some fun
well we're starting with b3 danny so
what do you think of jan's opening
choice is he just
you know getting his feet wet or is he
just saying to lavon
we're not having standard opening prep
today this isn't going to be a
theoretical i don't know it'll be
interesting because
you and i asked that question mbl if you
play yawn in the next round
is this a preview in terms of you know
are you going all in right
prep prep uh to be showed maybe this is
a preview of what yawn strategy would be
which is no i'm not i'm not gonna mess
with anything that i might be using in
the candidates coming up i'm gonna be
focused on some awkward blitz openings
and it does look really weird because
there's a knight on h3 but that knight
will in the future go to f4 white will
push that c2 pawn to c4
and the bishwan g2 will try to make use
of being on a very nice diagonal if you
compare the bishops the bishop on h7
versus the bishop on g2 you're trying to
pry open those diagonals to make your
bishops better pieces but it seems
easier for white to do so ooh
this is another way to kind of justify
the knight being on h3 everybody is you
play for e4 because this pawn chain
is conducive to a pawn storm and now the
knight on h3 normally on a square like
f3 is not in the way
of the f-pawn rushing up the board so
interesting
um lavonne is going into his first
mini think of the day if this is a sign
of things to come you and i are not
going to have a lot to offer in terms of
opening theory today robert it's going
to be
buckled up with everybody else let's
just you know let's see what kind of
instructive things we can learn about
you know unorthodox positions um
and here comes that knight to f4 right
because the d5 pawn now is a target
watch out for a timely
bishop takes f6 not now because once you
take on f6 and black takes back
the rook on a1 is under attack but
you're trying to remove one of the
defenders
of that d5 pawn i think he might be onto
something though i mean they're
you know well lavonne is the guy who
normally loves himself a good
old-fashioned exchange sack
so maybe maybe jan doesn't go for that
but again let's bring up the analysis
board and just show very quickly the
basic tactics robert
was talking about takes takes you are
not quite jake and baking without losing
the rook here
but this is on the agenda now to think
about
and see what white wants to do to
undermine this this is an interesting
position this bishop on h7 feels odd
robert it's like
you know hitting a wall but it also
could end up being a sneaky sort of
ninja regaining you know rejoining the
fight later on
if anything about this pawn structure
changes
yet actually you just made a good point
it made me realize that that bishop will
just come back to f5
the vision doesn't have to stay on h7
anymore because white has already
removed that pawn from e4 so by
releasing the tension
you did create a problem that black just
saw by pushing the pawn to d4
but you've also given more access to
that light square bishop
look at this knight come to f1 and after
d4 come right back because of the newly
opened squares
given that the pawn advance this is good
good old-fashioned family fun here the
high level
shuffling of these two heavyweights uh
good positional stuff just to recognize
you don't have to marry yourself to a
plan right you committed knight f1
to go to e3 to try to undermine the pawn
and then go right back as soon as the
squares are made available i like that
by jan although
let's see the computer's starting to
like black position here i wonder is it
because the e file will be opened up and
belonged to black
or and i'm guessing is the bishop on b2
danny right that's a bad piece yeah it
makes sense
uh but you know it's funny because when
you said that and sorry to
interject here but we said why is black
better we often have this
exact same thought process like well
we're not really sure who's better here
and
the players they're looking at this
position in lavon is thinking well do i
bring that bishop to f5 now
you don't really think am i much better
am i
you don't think in terms of computer
evaluation but i do get the sense that
uh lavon must be enjoying his position
more now that
it's clarified so yeah
yeah it's weird because if yeah if you
just look at the structure here
you have to like you have to like black
a little bit because the bishop on bt as
you said is not the most active piece
and
a way you might think of undermining and
opening things up might actually give
you know more purpose to to black's
pieces so
lavon is on the think and he's down a
minute on the clock so
um that's that's a small nod i guess in
uh upon she's direction but uh
not a huge i get this is not like
someone taking time robert because they
don't know what they're doing this is
lavon
calculating i think i was just gonna say
to commit to a plan
and maybe g5 was on the agenda because i
was spying how many squares does that
knight have not many not many good ones
yeah but you know what it does make your
c2 c3 idea
more powerful in the future um because
with this pawn now on g5
if that diagonal can really open up
black's king and be in some danger but i
like the
current state of affairs and i think
kicking that knight back to e2
then black can swing that rook to e8 try
to take over the e-file
white has less space for his pieces so
keeping more peace on the board
is beneficial uh for lavon
yeah it's uh pretty interesting yawn now
on the thing is deciding i mean to me
knight e2 seems like
the no-brainer because going to h3 feels
awkward but maybe he thinks going to h3
has
outside chances of not necessarily a
sacrifice but even other moves to try to
open up the king like you're talking
about right i mean if the knight is on
h3 and you do eventually open up this
bishop okay no he just
no i was just trying to think what is he
thinking about could be 92 seem like a
no-brainer but he does eventually play
it
yeah because 93 actually was a required
piece sacrifice from the looks of it
right your knight gets trapped on h3
so you're like yeah right right so
your idea with the sacrifice in g5 is
very interesting but i guess yan
he's like let me let me be calm for game
one
i doubt he likes his position um you
know he's just chilling there
with uh uh his hand on his chin here but
i don't really like white's position i
don't see the future in it and it just
seems
easier to play for lavon at this point
agreed and now notice that black is no
longer
down on the clock just tuning in uh yawn
at some point was up by a minute but no
not not anymore um you know if we had to
rank the time controls here
between these two guys who we know very
well probably
you know the reason we agreed with this
mortar just that slightly is that if we
reach bullet
john does seem to have the you know
maybe the slight nod so
lavonne i think i think would want to
have a game a game or two in his favor
as far as the five minute or three
minute goes
okay it's very close to a toss-up in
fact by the way you said it was close
is this the closest to smarter chess
stats that predicted any match in the
first round
56 and 40. i think it is i can't recall
a match that was closer but i also don't
listen to smart chess's predictions
hard right you dream about them all the
time thinking about it all the time
those are called nightmares danny you
know what it's like to have your kid
wake up screaming
that's what it's like for me well i saw
cm back to the beginning highlighting on
in the chess tv chat that the knight on
c4 was also running out of squares but
not not really true because e5 i think
was pretty much always on the agenda
and now that this has changed i'm
starting to get a little more nervous
for black's position
because i just feel like if c3 comes it
might be worth whatever weakness the d3
pawn becomes to open up things here
and actually black's going to play b4
next move i have a feeling because of
your idea with c3
and that way i can shut down the queen
side but that also removes most of
black's winning chances so
i i feel like if the queen drops back
because it just did black can play
there it is b4 and good luck getting
your pieces open
if you're watching yeah that's that's
painful
that's yeah awkward but but you know
danny
what does black do right like if you
give black three or four free reasonable
moves not hey let me go win a piece
what does black do to crack white
structure it's very solid yeah it's a
good point
in an instructive question in general by
mr hess for those who don't know
because one of the common ways you
should think about approaching a
position is if you had three or four
moves
what would what would you be doing to
improve your pieces
um not exactly clear because the
drawback
even though it seems very very
far-fetched robert is if somehow this
bishop
gets anywhere on the board right that
could undermine these these weaknesses
on the dark squares
um they could be it could be more of a
more harm than good
right and i i agree with you
and you know that's the real pond
weakness is
when you look across white structure
where are you going to attack the a2
pawn that's very far away from the rest
of the board
and i don't think your queen can go
venture over there in a timely manner so
i do think that the position should
peter out this should be
a split point but stranger things have
happened
in a time scramble and we're getting to
one minute left for each player
it'll be the first preview we'll have
into bullet as far as what happens in
this
in this game here because i don't think
we're going to have a lot of clarity
until
real time pressure ensues so
here we go king f1 nice little subtle
right little shuffle puck
i'm looking at bishop f5 because i'm
trying to force white's hand do you play
g4 or did you bring your knight back to
g1 oh he put a4 himself
so you cannot take on passant what you
can legally take ambassador i would not
advise it
because then your a5 pawn will fall and
then your queen side is collapsing so
why did you try to close up the
structure over there
and super close not a lot to it
yawn is up 30 seconds on the clock but i
don't know that it's going to matter too
much we might just have a
both sides feel each other out they uh
just call it peace in the first round
here huh and
lavon down to 27 seconds he has half the
remaining time
that jan does and we are going to see is
this going to be the lavon from the
bullet chess championships where he uh
made the semi-finals if i'm
not mistaken and will he be able to keep
peace and his position looks fine
he's great position that's totally cool
but nothing really to do
of note funny i forgot about that and
remember he made it to the semi-finals
and was also playing on horrible
internet wherever he was i think he was
on some leg of the grand chess tour and
the lobby wi-fi was just not having it
he ended up losing several games purely
because of disconnection and
it was awesome because we had sightings
of i think michael adams made an
appearance in the background
yeah yeah yeah who's walking by like
what is aronian doing here playing
bullet in the lobby
okay so danny that's what you talked
about those queenside pawns can white's
king
run into the game i don't think so but
that's the ideas kd3 king e4 king d5
just
jet that king into the action no and
even though when i highlighted it many
moves ago it was kind of just
far-fetched or sort of instructional in
nature but you have to think about
advanced pawns in the middle game
everybody are a space advantage and
they're crippling
the backward pawns but in an end game
advanced pawns if you haven't exposed or
used them in some way
are often targets and it does seem
far-fetched i don't see a clear way in
but if you could if you could get this
king or this bishop in any sort of
aggressive spot black definitely has
more weaknesses than white
and four seconds though for lavon he
needs to keep pace because
if you say play bishop e8 here the
threat bishop takes f7 and then the g5
pawn so
okay he made a big decision with f4
and is it a good one because now i guess
you can't take on f7 there would have
been the inter meso of taking on g3 with
check
and now the position is so close that
hey this looks
yeah they agree okay and they just
agreed to a draw that final closure of
the position let's bring up the analysis
board just to show
exactly how clear that was right you're
literally talking about a deadlock here
no way in for anybody and this knight
can sit on e5 and
did it literally laugh in the face of
danger put the king on h8 for fun just
to prove a point i think you could
that's how close the position is that
does seem like the
type of thing you would do just i would
do that i would i would actually have
already flagged in the game though so it
you know even with the increment
um but all right look at this now this
is going to be my kind of match sorry
let's bring back the analysis board to
show the opening while i was focused on
the end game
we have a night or ladies and gentlemen
and we have theory here
so with lavon taking the white pieces he
goes anti-yondapan machine plays
mainline stuff with queen e2
not as popular as the traditional queen
to d2 but knight to c6 to be fair
was also already a slightly unique move
order uh and uh this is going to be
a theoretical battle here with with
white now
um see i don't know i don't know the
theory here
before it came to b1 just to show
something very quickly it takes two
seconds right you say that again
before king to b1 was played right it
looks like c4
should win a piece because the knight is
pinned on d5 to the queen but the queen
goes to c7 go to the c file pin the c
pawn getting out of the pin and you've
created more problems for yourself than
it's worth
by pushing a pawn from your king okay
well this will be interesting again
we've been talking a lot about opening
prep everybody because
of of dawn uh if he gets by this he's
playing mbl
and you know they are leading the
candidates and just what are
what cards are these guys showing in
these online events these days knowing
that
if and when over the board chess ever
resumes we'll have a candidates and
maybe eventually a candidate to take on
magnus carlson in the world championship
so
but there's a lot of money in online
events these days so these guys aren't
holding many punches back
it's true and for lavon he's typically
we know him as a d4 player
we know that he can play with both hands
expression chess when you can play with
e4 or d4 on the first move right
um so he makes his choice so far in
this matchup by playing e4 in the longer
time control so speaking of holding your
prep
lavonna roni had a great norway chest
the recently concluded event
that happened he had a very strong
performance gained a bunch of ratings so
maybe
he is also trying to keep his openings
to himself to continue
his path back towards the top two rating
spots
yeah i like that i haven't heard that
expression while he who plays with both
hands
that sounds like my nickname from a past
life
he who plays with both hands um but okay
um
we've got uh yeah no but you're right
though normally when i think of lavon i
do think of a d4 player mostly so if
this becomes a theme today
even if it is theory maybe maybe you're
right it's it's theory that's avoiding
prep still
um we've got about six thousand of you
on twitch
four thousand of you on youtube the
matches early so thanks for being here
remember you can go play guess the move
i saw someone on chess tv
just asking that a second ago there's a
button right below the chest tv player
you can click
and you'll be taken to live chess and uh
instantly following
every game as it starts so go play guess
the move to win cash prizes and if
you're looking for the button
our mods can maybe help share a link on
twitch and youtube and on chess tv all
you got to do is
just click right below the player in
front of you
the real question i have danny is dragon
b70 winning guess the move again
is that's what happened today he's he's
won he's won i think three of the four
matches so far
wait do you know who was playing indian
lad we have
gm's joining to guess the move oh i love
it i can type
and by the way if you want to see you do
you do a command slash
guessing you just do a command slash
guessing and you can see everyone who's
currently playing guess the move
and yeah indian lad is playing dragon
b70 of course title players
um but yeah there you go um all right
back to this position john got the
better of it it seems
and just looking regardless of what the
computer says everybody just objectively
normally black if black is getting
pressure before white has done
anything with the english attack pawn
storm no real
uh side effects of having the king in
the center
you have to like black and these kind of
night orbs i always say if you start
moving pawns around your king position
in a race game it's usually a bad sign
um and look at this
king f7 the king is that's how good it's
getting from black your king is not
going to castle
but it's perfectly safe here the queen
on a4 is
running out of squares sneakily that
queen could get trapped over there
and also look at the c3 square if black
had a free move queen takes c3 is what
i'm looking at
with a knight fork at the end of it
let's show that to the analysis board we
shout
we shall go queen takes c3 oh man
delicioso dora even the computer likes
you robert see you don't always have to
hate computers in your life
look at that queen take c3 is on the
agenda for black
but you also highlight if i make another
random move on the analysis board that
the queen's kind of getting trapped and
i think queen takes c3 is just winning
but even b5 and b4 is coming forget the
a pawn i don't even need it right if i
pry open counter play
that's all i need in a race position
like this where both sides are looking
for checkmates so yeah this this is not
a great
game two for lavon aronian right now and
queen takes either is possible right now
would not be surprised if john goes
ahead and steals that pawn
it's free there's i bet there's some
sort of trick now the bishop guards c2 i
just have a feeling
knowing the coffeehouse trickster that
levon ironian has been called
i have i'm just gonna play queen dick c3
to see what the computer says
okay maybe it is okay i i'm gonna go
back now that's like flirting with
danger
look but don't touch look but don't
touch the but it looks like it actually
did work for black
so he's just playing the smart you know
coordinating move of rook to d and maybe
this queen is going to get trapped on a5
like maybe that's
really his plan is to eventually play b6
they forget the apon right i mean it's
got to be just a crushing attack here
you've got
everybody where it's supposed to be over
here
and g4 okay so this is what you need but
okay b6
the queen has one square after b6 queen
takes a6 only move
and there must be a way to trap that
queen right danny there has to be a way
um ah yeah there is yeah c7 knight c7
after that oh nice c7 is that it so b6
26 knight c7 because the queen is losing
let's go to the analysis board and show
it because i still don't know why he's
not playing it but if it's b6 takes and
knight c7
the queen would have to go to a7 just
winning the queen
he just he just missed that i think
that's
pretty straightforward b6 queen takes a6
only move knight c7 again everybody
every square is guarded right now by a
black piece the queen has no squares
between a7 and rook a8 robert was right
i mean john is taking his time here but
he's now gone away and the evaluation
has swung
wildly back i mean we were looking at a
position that if yon had found b6
it was plus seven for black the queen
was bye-bye
yeah it's uh in some ways you know we're
here we see the
eval bar saying it's hugely in black's
favor you're like okay let me go find an
idea that could win the game
let's go trap the queen so it is much
easier in this case
to find it but for jan he has to find
that he's
so strong he's one of the best handful
of players on this planet
he's more than capable of finding that
but his position still remains excellent
but especially because he has a little
bit of time here i mean he's still he's
still up about two minutes on the clock
but
when you're when you have more time i
mean you just feel like you should slow
down there and figure out the way to
convert on that but all right everybody
is primed for liftoff right
like at saga i need to pounce love right
[Music]
i could say come on
you're all right you are right danny
exotic over there like everything
happens
and it's soggy and wild looking as you
crouch up on his man bun
like a tiger
all right v6 a while ago
ready to pounce um by the way if queen
takes a6 is knight b4 will move now
because queen takes c2
what i think it is yeah i think it is
let's see if he finds it
knight before the queen can retreat and
all you're all you're
actually winning is the bishop here
unless there's something on a2 now that
would be wild
no i think you're right it's over the
bishop pair so
john's position still looks very good
because the bishops are strong in a
position like this with action happening
on both sides of the board
and at the end of some of these lines
maybe black can just gobble up the f3
pawn because if that pawn
is removed look out for e5 and f5
becoming queens later in this game
right so he takes it there's got to be
something on the light squares here like
i mean
i think that's what he's going for he's
just like look there's no way white's
surviving this queen a4
um you can throw in a tempo but i
actually don't want to chase the queen
to this side of the board everybody you
don't want to yeah so queen a4 makes a
lot of sense
now just something where is it
okay it says seven rook takes c3 check
right like it just take on c3 take on a2
dude that's it let's do it to the
analysis board
if you just found that rook takes c3 the
computer believes it you're right it's
made in six
well i saw the eval bar it says maiden
seven so i
trust me i wasn't just being like oh i
could see mate and seven off the top of
my head no problems but i mean
this move at the end look how freaking
dirty that is
oh we found it rook takes c3 and we're
gonna have a good day everybody
that's how you that's how you have
liftoff wait wait wait danny um
it said mate in four i think if that's i
can see that yeah so young clearly
always you know what it was
that was sick oh my
god if you're playing guess the move and
you found queen takes a2 and yawn didn't
if you can prove it to me with a
screenshot you get a diamond membership
okay because that's the move you should
have guessed and yawn didn't see it
by the way he better convert this
okay to the analysis board we got to
show it levon's
shaking his head he's not happy about
you guys on king b1
queen takes a2 and then bishop takes and
if the king goes back you just give
check and rook a8
someone just said in chat that needs to
be in puzzle rush uh platinum member
fire fangled if you send me a message
with this game please i'll remember
to submit these uh these tactics to
puzzle rush seriously
send me send me a message with these
games because i forget
hell i don't remember my name half the
time so uh i forget a lot of things so
send me a message
uh fire laying lead
bang lead and um all right let's bring
back the the end of that game real quick
just to show it we got a little
distracted with the hype but that was
still still a fanciful finish robert not
quite the queen sack for mate but yawn
does get the job done
and it's time for lavon to rethink his
uh his english attack i guess
yeah i wonder if levon will switch to d4
or c4 playing english
that is his standard style and well john
sticks to his b3
and these kind of openings right white
is playing with pieces
and black is getting more control over
the center with pawns
than is typically the case and danny i
know you're going to crack a joke so
i'll crack it first
does it not remind you of the bad
closest science i played
since i was a kid
i don't even have to because uh me and
don you just had some fun together
talking about about your opening so i i
already got out of my system for the day
um but yeah no although jokes aside you
know now that d4 has been played he
righted the wrong of the close sicilian
and uh has has sort of transitioned into
what is
what is this now this is a double
fianchetto
hedgehog sicilian dragon i mean what is
this
you're asking the wrong person if you
want to know the names of openings
that was a long address double fee and
kettle hedgehog sicilian dragon
and look at this bishop g4 was played
and he drops the knight back to e2
because typically you don't want to push
upon to f3 as that makes the dark
squares
much more loose and can be problematic
for your king
but dropping the knight back to e2 feels
very passive and look what levon just
did he brings queen to c8
guess what here comes the eventual
bishop of h3 try to trade off
your nice fiance bishop
apparently grandmaster indian lad does
legit want that cash prize he's not
giving up on guess the move so there you
go
um right now what
not even in first place right now so if
you've ever wanted to beat a grandmaster
guess the move is probably your easiest
path to success we'll go to the analysis
board real quick
to show the opening that robert was
talking about and again
jokes about the close sicilian aside
that's not
the the main thing that black has
advantages in this structure is that you
have control over the center while
maintaining flexibility this pawn can
move one twice you could actually go for
e6 and d5 so
you know one of the reasons why white
doesn't play like uh
doesn't play things like d3 and and go
for another plane and give black that
flexibility is because
because of that because of all the
options black has so white transitions
to an open center
but this is a weird way to do it and i'm
with robert that the tempe black has
gained
now bishop h3 this already just looks
like
like white has gotten like a bad version
of a meroxie bind right all the weak
dark squares and
and black is kind of ahead of an
initiative here straight strange opening
choice by john who's clearly going out
of his way as white today to avoid
mainline theory
yeah that's certainly the case and
typically in these moroxy bind
structures
i mean this knight doesn't really want
to be on d2 it's limiting the scope
of any major pieces that come down to d
file and black is very solid no matter
the muroxy bind position it's often that
black is cramped
but very solid and if you look at the
pawn structure white's pawn structure is
actually looser think about
pawn breaks how can white create a pawn
break not
so easy to accomplish without creating
more vulnerable squares but on
for black a6 to b5 for instance e6 and
d5 comes to mind
so it just seems easier for black to
control the
kind of imminent dynamic of the position
and this will be one of those
destructive moments we rarely get as
human
brand masters will say or or i'm not but
we'll pretend that i'm playing one on tv
today
that rob and i would disagree with the
general way an engine evaluates it
because the algorithms are taught to
evaluate things mathematically like
space
there's an objective viewpoint of white
has a little bit more space but
this is one of those positions where the
longer the game goes
and when black does eventually
manufacture some sort of breakthrough
white is going to have more potential
weaknesses here
and the the objective math giving white
an edge because of space i would
actually disagree with i think the black
is
like it's in a very comfortable position
here you could even consider moving the
knight and offering a trait of dark
sport bishops
just to dominate the dark squares like
if you imagine black getting a piece on
one of these beautiful outpost squares
somehow so
anyway i like lavon's position we liked
him in the first game as black robert
we'll see if he can do a little better
this time
you know what i don't like though this
is clock management because right now
john it's up a minute and a half and
it's not an easy position to play
despite the fact that we both
like black's position we think it's
sturdy it's not easy to actually
progress
do you play b5 now or is that too risky
opening the c5 do i try to play for d5
or is that not realistic so i do think
some of these decisions
are more difficult than i initially made
it seem
but i still like levon's position even
if i think he is
struggling about that clock you said it
well the only thing we don't like is is
the clock management right and
um you see john had to play f3 because
he was worried about the queen and
knight doing double duty over here
um
so we'll see if if levon can speed up a
little bit knight d3
a little awkward yep he's trying to
clearly trying to bring his
pieces towards that queen side and and i
think he was kind of threading c5 i
guess
or definitely a possibility
and now c5 is is possible if he wants to
i guess
there is some downside of a knight d4
shot at some moment because then the
rook on c8 attacks c5 as well so you
have to be careful
before pushing that pawn but it's
something to consider definitely now he
put queen e3 so
maybe it is what's next well we see the
position slowly kind of creep into
to be very comfy for black like has a
teeny bit
of an edge in these positions and likely
either c4 will become a target
an isolated pawn of some kind or you'll
or you'll blink first but usually taking
is bringing more activity to black's
pieces
the one long-term thing you always have
to think about in these dragon sicilian
kind of meroxybund structures
is watch out for a quick simplification
and then suddenly at the end of a line
where the smoke cleared white actually
has a two on one
on the queen side now black always gets
the breakthrough of d5 in exchange for
that anytime there's a trade here
but you got to watch out a little bit
for end game transitions when you're
black and somehow a quick outside pass
pawn
i think that's an incredibly instructive
point in what we might see because i
would
probably do exactly that take on a7
take on b5 and maybe play f4 because if
the queen's off the board your king is
not going to feel unsafe
when you start pushing your pawns but he
doesn't go for that he goes for knight
f1 instead
and what if you take on c4 now you're
giving yeah yeah i was going to say i
don't like john's decision
oh yes yeah that was his idea then
because you and i were both thinking
why did yon do that to give himself an
isolated pawn but he has some clear
really has some tricky idea
that's a really nice idea by jan because
he's creating complications
out of a position that seemed quite tame
he is still up a minute on the clock
and now that two on one majority that
becomes very difficult to
hold in an end game if you're thinking
from lavon's perspective
because most of the action is focused in
the center i can use the queenside pawns
as a decoy
yeah and he also he forced this move
knight d3 right i mean because
knight d6 would have lost the d6 pawn
everybody so that's
that was a key thing that robert was
saying is that now he forces that
two-on-one end game
where white has um
but you know as long as the queens are
on the board robert look at that move
queen b7 lavon just said you missed your
chance buddy guess what i'm going to do
i'm playing for d5 and i'm going to open
up these light squares
i like it you can also play for e5 as
black and throw your knight into d4 so
then f1 is clearly misplaced and now d5
looks good i mean now the knight is
getting into the game
let's bring up the analysis board
because i actually think john's idea was
really interesting but he should have
combined it with mine and robert's
approach which was
take on a7 at some point maybe first
and and head to the end game where he
has the two on one and some sort of end
game like this
knight end games are close to king and
pawn endings this would have been
different than what we now have levon
did not have to be asked twice to keep
the queens on the board with the
transition
of the c pawns which makes d5 uh
a real option so i'm i'm getting a
feeling that lavon might strike back
here and level the score in this match
the position is starting to look very
good for him time is becoming about even
and that's always
not always i shouldn't say that but
often a good indicator right danny when
one player is well ahead in the clock
the position starts getting
a little murkier and they're also using
that time advantage and
it goes away completely so i do think
that lavon as we see his face on screen
too
he is deeply concentrated and probably
quite concerned because after e takes d5
black doesn't have to recapture that
pawn will be pinned on the diagonal so
block could actually play move like
knight to e7
or even stronger by knight to b4 hitting
the rook and then going knight takes d5
with all sorts of discoveries
yeah no let's show that real quick i
mean that's the main point we've been
highlighting is that
the opening of the position oops the
opening of the position
can only favor black with a king here
and a bunch of pawns that
have wandered away too far so so john
doesn't do that
he plays knight f3 oh but does 95 in the
end 95 oh we missed it 95 is coming
there it is 95 is coming oh and
and jan just he said something that
probably isn't
appropriate for our audience here i
don't know he didn't seem very happy
yeah he's whispering for the kids
watching
he's whispering just you know sweet
nothings
um
and the point everybody is that the rook
on c1 is not defended
and the queen is also under attack so
you would have to
combine those pieces maybe queen move to
protect the rook
but once the rook is captured the queen
can't capture back without dropping the
knight on f3
which is now attacked two times that was
about as tricky as you can make it
because yawn is going to take with check
um and of course it's still winning for
black but that was a creative little
little move by yon to say i'm i'm lost i
blundered but
look it's still going to make you beat
me here up the exchange
and lavon takes a breath he's winning he
knows it so he plays f6
oftentimes that can weaken your king
here white's king is actually in worse
shape so rook c2
check and that queen can come into d5
and help you probably land to check me
in the near future
here it comes i mean
how does white drum okay g4 so let me
ask you how white drums up some counter
play
that does seem to be the best chance but
h5 for black just
go all in go check me yeah do it open
the king
although then maybe queen a7 check i
forgot the queen gets slide over there
and
oh yeah don't blunder me let's kill that
real quick
if h5 queen a7 check king h6 would be a
problem
yeah that would be good oh wait
he did allow the queen it okay but he's
got different ideas walking the king out
also he put us on h6 rather than h5 so
that was interesting
yeah i think okay now
there's g5 is for g5
victory march look at the clock by the
way jan is literally living on the
increment here and he's going nope
where's the mate there has to be a
checkmate somewhere there has to be made
but john is living on the increment here
okay we're going to have a time scramble
here we're going to have a photo finish
yawn there could be some kind of
perpetual if you're not careful like
quinn h yeah you could lose now
now lavon is down to two seconds oh my
gosh
and look how well placed the queen on c3
is though guarding
f6 just perfect that's huge now rook f2
queen d6 no checks for you now we're
waiting for rook f2 there you go
now he's got it i think queen c6 no the
checks are gonna happen
oh no more checks that's really well
done technique but where's the knockout
three oh nice nice finish
oh that was nasty oh man
we'll bring up the analysis board it's
mate rook f3
found with seconds on the clock the
point is knight takes f3
queen takes f3 oh wait no no wait wait
it wasn't mate
no it's not me it was just it was a
trick
well you probably win these king and
pawning games as my guess but
that was uh that's a good point
that's a good point you can take either
way and win the kingdom upon ending okay
all right so lavon wasn't just tricking
his way to that particular time scramble
victory he was also
converting oh yeah
but that is good to see if you are a
levon aronian fan that
in these time scrambles he clearly has
what it takes
to convert great positions and to find
these uh
simplifications that are not easy to
spot at first glance
yeah and at the same time you got to
give credit to yon because he was he
blundered right straight up
but what did he do right he gathered
himself and said all right well the best
chance i have
is x right to go to this queen and
knight thing and he almost got himself
you know a draw there right and i think
that um
that's a that's a good thing to see just
as far as like
you know when you know you're in the
right mental frame of mind robert like
talk a little
because what's the psychology of not
just when things are going well but when
you screw up
right and the ability to take a breath
and then gather yourself
is probably a much more you know less
talked about skill but
just as important skill right yeah and
there is a time and place to resign and
that game certainly was not one of those
instances but it is difficult when
you're worse to
have the motivation to fight back
especially when you're much worse you
blunder a clean exchange
you know that objectively you're lost
but to have that willpower
and to sustain that effort it's
difficult to see yan do that in the
early going
he knows it's going to be a tough battle
these two competitors have so much
respect for one another
and you're right it is good to see if
you're a fan of yana pannashi
when you see him fighting until the very
last second and he honestly had chances
until the very end
yeah he almost swindled himself a draw
there and
shout out to our uh our sub there cat
rocket move because that's a 12 month
sub
we appreciate a full year of support
there um
5 000 of you on youtube 8 000 on twitch
and
thanks for being here look at levon's
position to start this one this is uh
he goes he goes back to e4
so he's gonna stick to that even though
we think of lavon sometimes as a d4
player
but this is a lot better than that than
that bogus english attack he had in game
two he's
clearly better in this position and
black has some trouble on the a file
yeah black eyes trouble on the a file
also white can consider pushing that
pawn to b5 and maybe even to b6 and then
he does it immediately right it's like
don't even bother
thinking about the position because
white has a protected pawn
by a bishop and the pawn a5 there's
already one piece attacking it
but watch out in the future if multiple
pieces go and
the knight gets into b3 hits that a5
pawn maybe then i can even come to
b3 to d4 trying to get to these
vulnerable e6 and c6 squares
this does not look very good i agree f5
is a move that
well from an aggressive point of view
makes sense you're trying to undermine
the protection of the pawn here and
unleash the bishop
but it also is clearly clearly a move of
some level of desperation because
super weakening to black's light squares
i like your idea it probably is a little
too slow for this exact position because
black can take and then take here twice
but there's got to be some of the move
here okay so he takes first
and you know what jenny is funny the e7
pawn is a backward pawn like not only
are the squares weak at the end of this
if you let's say some pieces clear out
in the e file or rook comes to e1 we're
going to be
just putting pressure on e7 into the end
of the game so that's what lavon is
transitioning to here
yeah even even the e3 square i mean
there's there's this potential that
white is in a position to really
go gangbusting over here on this uh this
e file here i mean this is
gonna be a problem the e pawn and
black really needs to keep this knight
on e5 because if white's bishop gets to
d4 and you trade off that fiance bishop
that rook on a3 is going to land on g3
and go checkmate that black king right
so you have to
be careful in all directions at this
point trading there was almost necessary
for black because of the threat you
already highlighted some route that pony
was headed to the e6 square so black had
to get it off
um but yeah this is a position where
white holds all the cards
i think patience
patience would be a virtue here i mean
what could you do you could just play
queen d3 guard the pawn and build up
e file plans rookie one bishop g5 you
could even play bishop d4 right away
here
try to do your idea in fact he does it
um i kind of like that i know it sacks
the b-pawn but that's more my style
you know it's just a good decision
frankly i mean
the king is not going to survive without
defending yeah so if you go queen takes
beef
oh my god he does it because you can
combine all these ideas bishop g7
king takes g7 then play rook e1 i was
gonna say queen
check i mean you can combine them as my
point like if they're rookie one you
don't even have a good way to defend e7
because if you put a rook on f7 or e8 i
bishop h5 coming
yeah to kick your rook off this uh these
squares let's just let's bring up the
analysis board there's gonna be a lot of
tactics here to show as
lavon tries to finish this one off i
mean
taking and just
i was looking at some idea like this
where i could swing but maybe that's too
slow black can stop rook g3
you were just saying just rookie one
here
and the best news danny is you have
ideas of queen a one check as well to
win the a5 pawn if that's
moves it's just too much is happening
and it's all
bad for black robert's point everybody
is that regardless of how you might try
to defend it bishop h5
is on the agenda and your rook is not
only under the attack
but seven pawn is a problem but there's
i wonder if there's something even
better like some like inner inner meso
like rook b3 you force the queen back
i don't even know
it's funny danny there's like subtle
inter messes there
i feel like those are ones that are
easiest for me to miss personally
because i'm sometimes get this laser
focus
on the attack and he goes for this line
where he uh
trades and puts queen on a1 with the
check but i get so focused on like how
to conclude the game
that sometimes that little move is the
best way forward it just
for me it's hard to register yeah i
don't even know if it was i mean it just
felt like a really tricky thing to do
and kick the queen back
but lavon obviously calculated something
or we wouldn't be here and he's
his next move will probably be revealing
um
yeah i think rookie one is i mean this
just oh you know he's
he has some variations he's like bishop
e2
i was just gonna say that that you move
the bishop with tempo to get rook g3 so
like
but i was calculating it oh no this is
even better because you get the rook in
first so now bishop e2 isn't even
stacking a piece
wow so yeah because rook g3
oh my gosh and actually if black plays
f4 the bishop goes back to g4 and into
e6 wait what is the queen
he's playing for pawns over there
interesting he gave up on the uh it was
obviously it's hard you know they you
know they don't have the same eval bar
telling you that there's blood in the
water and
it'll be a shark but he's just kind of
converting on what seems simple he's
wins the pawn still has this bad king to
expose
but definitely definitely not the most
direct
way to victory some sort of path of
bringing the rook to the king's side was
doctor ordered there his position is
still great right
yes much weaker the bishop on b7
is staring into a wall that's defended
and so white's pieces
pretty much across the board are in
better shape but it just feels like
there was a knockout there
and i didn't see it concretely but it
did feel like there was one
and maybe he's gonna find a different
one but like uh
i don't i'm trying to figure out where
does this rook belong
for white do i go rook b3 to swing it
back to g3 to go rook
b4 potentially i love this
queen g5 if you could just put the
bishop on e6 it's lights out
you can't get there no
but this is a tough move to deal with
because rook f7 and rookie eight are
both met by bishop h5
i guess i thought so so bishop h5 there
will be a rook g7 you're
just barely hanging on there yeah you
got to be careful because you don't want
to lose the d5 pawn
uh but he's he's smart to bring the h
pawn up right because he can just push
that pawn all the way to h6 and then
put bishop h5 that's what he needs to
get the e7 pawn to fall
just keep pushing push it right h5 danny
just keep on going
alpha alpha zero
put it on h6
that's a good move too but by the way h6
and bishop back to h5 with the
oh wait yeah the rook was hanging lol
wake up
going on here but that would have been
the best idea
had the rook not been under attack so
i'm with you
yeah this is this is doing work right
now and i think that
jan will not repeat this opening this
opening
it did not go well for him yeah this
particular one
will back up and run through it uh
quickly the
cement it in our in our storyline for
the day in case yawn does
maybe make the mistake of repeating it
but early on in these matches you see
the five minute portion
both sides kind of feeling each other
out um as the time controls get faster
less time to think that sounds like a
yogi berra
but as the time controls get faster
there's less time to think
yeah i was i was thinking the same thing
full of just
incredible wisdom danny all right
all right oh this here comes queen g5
and it's rover yeah
because the bishop what
can he just please
on basant is dirty um and queen d4 is a
threat for mate on g7
so but there's rook takes g2
oh
[Laughter]
i actually think it's still wait i think
it is still winning
it is but i didn't see rook takes g2
because
because it takes yeah he goes for it
takes no i think there's no chat you
know it makes me seem like i
saw this all very i didn't even see rook
takes g2 as possible i'm gonna become
that's funny
well i was giving you the benefit of the
doubt i was like yeah on poisson is good
but there's rook takes g2 but turns out
it didn't matter you were right just
winning
um yeah but he is ten seconds left
uh wait he just missed queen c4 jack oh
he's got bishops
whoa oh man hey white is still winning
but what a wild
finish this position is here allowing uh
there's some sort of draw with bishops
oh my god
bishop d3 you trade on e2 and then you
go queenie six check i think and then
you can win
oh my god lavon let it slip
whoa what is going on oh my god he gives
him his queen he wins
oh god he can even just take
now ea queen and it's over
oh my gosh what a weird game that was
and yawn's playing it out here everybody
just to test lavon's uh
you know internet connection if you will
on the increment but let's bring back
the analysis board because
what a weird finish that was lavonne
played a masterful game but actually
blundered a draw here on bishop check
but it looks like black missed queen e6
this was the move robert and after king
d2 what's the
i mean this is a cool and i think i
think you can ache e7 maybe
wow oh wait you actually have queen e5
so you could take the rook
oh wow there's no queen c3 check because
you can block that's important
that's essential that that is yeah with
seconds and
clockwise finish there and lavon
just uh converts in in a crazy time
scramble and okay well this is going to
be a fun day today i think that
we we said this was going to be a
nail-biter if you're just tuning in the
smarter chef's predictions
uh confirmed by the team here closest
first-round matchup we've
we've uh predicted anyway right
and predictions are to give robert
aneurysms so that's why they're here
right they're not actually
you know the chess but we have predicted
a close match so don't go anywhere
and you know this is one of those
moments where i had mentioned
levon he's pretty solid as a player
and jan it seems like he's more
emotional and a lot of the top players
will say that he is
incredibly strong capable of winning
every term that he plays
but there are moments where he gets a
bit emotional and throws
his chances away so danny he's now down
in the score but it is very early i
don't think he's you know too bothered
by the score
but what do you make of the start do you
think that we might see a different yawn
come out soon
i wonder if if it continues to go this
way if he'll if he'll abandon
his unorthodox openings approach right
we know that yawn is one of the best
players in the world and one of the
most well prepared players in the world
um
so again if you're if you're just tuning
in i'll just back up quickly and go
through the opening this has been all
day
e3 by yawn and and this approach of
some sort of not very uh
well-traveled road by white has been
what uh
the pond richie's been doing and if he
falls behind in the match
does he abandon that approach i think
he's gonna fight
he will yeah but i think he will because
what he's been doing
has allowed lavonne a relatively easy
escape from the opening
stage and often when you're playing with
the black pieces
against a player of yawn's caliber these
super great masters
is you want to put pressure on your
phone early sometimes it's subtle
other times it's quite direct but the
point is that black has to make some
important decisions
that isn't just oh i'm blundering upon
now it's at the future
direction of the game and here you look
at the position
black has several options that look good
i would consider
bishop e6 simple development i would
consider queen to e7
i would consider moving my knight away
knight to d7
to open up my bishop on g7 so i feel
like black has
quite a bit of
what i was letting you finish i didn't
want to didn't want to take your
sandwich there
i first of all i supported every word
that was coming out of your mouth i
think a solid approach was uh
but that was a as far as prep goes
robert i know it's hard to say that
because there's no way they played
this is not this is not a an or you know
a very well-known opening
but the idea of the b-pawn being able to
be pushed there and not be taken
let's go to the analysis board why
couldn't
white just take the pawn right what a
wild decision there
i know e4 was hanging but
let's do it can you actually take this
i guess so at least that's the claim
so you take a nice
central pawn for your pawn closer to the
flank
so yeah there's there's no tricks here
everybody i mean among other things i
think black can just develop and
defend everything so there's the lavon
who took a lot of time
37 seconds to be exact uncorks b5 when
we were looking for
kind of a solid subtle maneuvering
approach and
lavon says no thank you guys i got this
let me drive
it's one of the many reasons that you
know he is
where he is and i am where i am is that
you know he
finds ideas like this just pretty
quickly and b5 is not something that
ever came to my mind it's like
an aggressive approach in a solid
position he's like you know i'm not okay
with just simple equality i don't want
to make
yon feel comfortable that he's just
going to hold the balance i don't know
i'm going to create some immediate
problems for him
that was quite beautiful
well black is a little bit better but
also has the d6 pawn to worry about
um did interesting position right
because you could
you could take and double the c pawns
but that actually increases white
strength
in regards to your pawn being weak so
most likely result is just equality here
i mean black can also trade here
everybody and then walk the king to e7
to make sure that this pawn is
not going to be forgotten but we'll see
if levon comes up with yet another
creative way to maybe
play for more than equality here but
your
ultimate point is a great one that even
though white's pawn structure looks
worse with double isolated c
pawns black has the easiest pawn to
target on d6
white has more space for the rooks what
does rooks need they need open lines
and with two rooks in the d-file hitting
the d6 pawn
and blacks work on d8 staring into its
own pawn protecting it
white's pieces are just better and quite
significantly better at that
yeah yeah yeah
so what do you think that lavon is
considering here
i'm wondering i mean one idea is
it's a little too slow sometimes you can
put a piece on a square that's protected
by a weak pawn with the idea that if
they ever trade
you take and you fix your weakness in
this case i think that that's just too
slow because
white has rook d1 and the threat of
trading is too much
but i was wondering if there was some
idea where h2 would be anyway i was
considering bishop b5 that was the short
answer i have no idea what yawn is
considering
now now bishop e5 is completely not
possible because it would blunder a
piece
right but you could you could even trade
and play bishop f8 i know that's
horrible i know don't yell at me
don't yell at me
it's actually a horrible idea e5 even
just wins okay now you can yell
yeah i'm not gonna yell at you because i
actually think it's not as bad as
we both initially thought but look what
he's doing lavon this whole game
hey i said i can be solid i can make
this position as balanced as possible
but let me avoid that but danny here's
42 seconds
and gone is over three minutes that's
been the story of the day i mean john
has had more time on the clock as he
does when he plays most opponents
but um
but it hasn't deterred lavonne i mean
he's converted obviously he has a
one-game lead
um black is saying hey i'm the one
playing for two results here
i'm not just going to sit passively and
defend my weak d6 pawn i want more
and he's defending it tactically because
somebody asked like wait wasn't that
pawn hanging directly
but black would have thrown in a rook a1
check and scooped off
the first let's show that tactic real
quick because that's an instructive one
never forget if you take pawns x-ray
tactics exist you check and take and the
rooks actually defend each other
through the white rook x-ray vision it's
perfect given i saw someone in
twitch chat earlier saying that love yon
is like superman and lavon is like
batman with the prep and the kryptonite
right
i like that reference i do too but i
never watched
that movie because it seemed like it was
gonna be horrible oh yeah no the dc
movies when are they gonna get it right
hashtag marvel
ftw um
but uh but it is an interesting thing
right i love the i love the uh the
reference there
the x-ray vision tactic was also
instructive and now black is
also still pushing a little bit it's
it's close to equality but
the king is going to be the more active
piece than the white counterpart
and that's a huge advantage in an engine
like this
i don't know and now also black's pawn
structure
it looks better because white has this
isolated b pawn it looks protected for
now
but once those bishops get traded that
pawn on b3 immediately a target
and there goes the bishops you have to
take with the rook
and i guess white is solid here because
you can put a second rook on the b5 but
the rook on c3 does stabilize the
position
and if i were young i would consider
starting to push some of the king side
pawns
but no he's worried he was worried about
rook b to a8 and
there it goes yeah i'm gonna say the
problem with that plan for
lavon is it looks pretty with the rooks
on the b file but where's the beef right
what's the finish so
instead lavon is going for something a
little more aggressive with the rooks
but now he has to trade back because his
yawn gets pressure on d6 so probably
this should be a draw
nice move very important move by yon
they're playing e5 because jan had
two separate isolated pawns now he'll
trade off one of his isotopes from
black's good pond
and it's mutually isolated pawns and
we'll see how this goes
mutually isolated yeah
i thought that was like a story of like
a
it sounds like a nicholas sparks like
love novel mutually isolated
you know enough dear john movies
for white so in certain scenarios if
black is forced
to you know trade the b-pawn for the
e-pawn that would
require the black king to start going
out to the queen's end okay that's not
happening black is too active and it's
just going to be
austin i imagine you're on there yan
says no i'll play for a little more now
you've gotten yourself under some time
pressure
john probably could have just checked
that one out right pickle this one home
as they say
take a draw um okay a no
and it's gonna be a draw but in theory
outside past pawns it should be better
for white if somehow if you could just
take here and the white king takes here
the problem is
black's king is more centralized so it's
not going to be that simple yeah we're
going to trade
well white's king is closer black's king
is more active and so
it's an easy cut off um
always remember outside passport
principles if somehow the starting was
black king here and white king here
white would be winning because of that
outside passer but as it was
we have a draw the old-fashioned way and
uh again
second draw of the day actually right
indeed that is the case and wait where'd
they go
i have no idea where the players are
going but it seems like they work
something out
that was odd yeah i i guess
they had asked for a okay a mutual
often and that is part of the rules
everybody that this is a grueling format
the scc
and let's go ahead and bring it back up
because we have a moment remind you that
the
90 minutes of five minutes and the clock
ticking
is something that always happens even if
you got to go to the bathroom doesn't
matter if your doorbell rings right the
clock doesn't stop
and you're actually not allowed to delay
rematching by more than any sort of
you know reasonable measure you can be
penalized but if the players agree
you know someone has to use the restroom
or you know someone has something
um then obviously we have no reason to
uh
to hold to that so someone had to go and
then guess what you gotta go and
speaking of which if you're on the go
why you gotta go some people gotta go
and they use the phone while they're on
the go
i should probably go away from this
rabbit hole that i'm going down but i'm
gonna keep going for it if you're on the
go grab the phone
you know what the most popular type of
puzzle brush is toilet puzzle rush
back to the chest robert so how do you
expect me to talk about
high-level chess after you have been
discussing bathroom breaks
you know there's a reason some people
wear pampers it allows you to pee-pee
without having to go anywhere
oh god i'm gonna be here all week don't
forget to tip your waitress
i was waiting for you to make that joke
you made it
in a much worse way than i expected i'm
not i feel like a disappointed high
school teacher
where i should be giving you detention
but i'm slightly amused so i won't do
that
right exactly no it's it's like when my
15 year old makes an inappropriate joke
and like my wife is in the room and i'm
like
like i don't want to acknowledge that it
was a good one right it's just not the
right audience right so i get it
yeah i also you know if i give you
detention i have to stay
you know late one day not really worth
my time but anyway back to this chest
position where we have
what looks like a kero con or like an
exchange karo khan
but it was from the sicilian so it's
interesting how
different openings can still lead to
yeah let's
let's back up real quick we'll bring up
the analysis board how in the world did
we get here because you said it was a
keracon and then i looked at the eco but
no it was a sicilian
oh okay duh it was an allopin but that
changes the structure remember
open sicilians occur with d4 allopin
idea with c3
it's going to lead to a different kind
of game don't blunder knight takes e4
very common trap everybody you lose your
pony out of the opening
i may or may not have fallen for that a
few times some people have to learn
things more than once okay
don't judge me but either way the
structure does eventually change
and we get i mean you called it a
keracon it could be
a number of different structures now and
i i
i do like what black has gotten assuming
that he doesn't lose the e pawn
for uh for without some defile
compensation coming like the d3 square
right there's much more hope than the
carrot con right yeah
i'm only four episodes in so don't ruin
anything for me just so you know i've
only seen the first four episodes of the
queen's gamut but i gotta get good job
dude
everybody in the world has watched and
is talking about the queen's gambit and
the critics love it you hear it was just
it was just raided on rotten tomatoes as
the best show of 2020.
okay and what's your point
i mean i personally love the boys season
two if i was doing the rankings i mean i
don't know i know i'm supposed to go
with the chess movie
but um i haven't seen the second season
of that either so you know what i'm a
little behind on my shows danny
have you seen the unicorn i feel like
you would really like that show but we
just want to talk about chess
so how did we get into a conversation
about because cecaro tweeted that he
thought the queen's gambit was the best
portrayal of chess in entertainment to
date
a lot of people feel that way so anyway
back to the chest so we're in an equal
position with nothing
but a ball point of jelly or white and
the extra pawn on the queen side
yeah so but b2 is clearly a target
there could be some problems on the e
file with a quick rookie a
hitting both minor pieces that are there
and why not queen e2 that's my first
instinct is just put my
bishop c5 with tempo instead interesting
i agree explain these things to me danny
bishop
five got all kinds of weird tempe to
calculate
we do one knight b2 the rook could go to
e8 i mean
to the batcave let's do it if queen to
d1
is played and you take with a tempe i'm
just saying i don't know and then i play
rookie a like oh there's knight d6
oh but then i have rookie two what was
the move why was probably winning there
i just i think it looks as complex as
you're making it out to be it really
does look like a position where
there are tactics on b2 but i guess
bishop f8 is always possible
yeah i guess you just take everything
directly
and in the end okay yeah big here take
care okay but all right so
lavonne played bishop c5 he's given yawn
some things to calculate
and he's still thinking here so it's
now for a change lavon up on the clock
and he's up that pawn
and rookie will be knight
well once we established the knight b2
was not an option i mean rookie was kind
of the only move so jan eventually plays
it i think we'll see a trade on d6
and white's gonna be up a pawn in the
end game yeah it's interesting how this
just
transitioned to a position where it's a
pretty clear extra pawn i thought that
black would have some huge compensation
but as i look at the position it seems
like it's just a
stable extra pawn and i'm not sure where
yon is going to have
sufficient compensation yeah
three degree degree degree um
when we first you know we're talking
about the position i thought black had
compensation on the default one of those
kind of
typical positions but now
even moves like queen b6 can be met by
bishop a3 so there's no like
you know there's no way to create more
than one problem here black would love
to have
you know a pin on the d file you've got
the pressure on the palm but i think
lavon will just play bishop a3 here
and he's like you said he's gotten out
of dodge and
has an extra pawn and indeed he does
and these are the positions that are
very frustrating for black
because if a queen trade is offered even
if it comes to the cost of doubling
white's pawns
you're like wait there is still that
extra pawn that remains so queen b3 for
instance you don't want to take on b3
you don't want to trade those queens
you're just down pawn and he plays queen
c2 keeping his queen closer
and taking control over this the second
rank because black would have enjoyed
planting a rook on e2 himself it just
looks like a
clean extra pawn to me at this point a
to d1 start tradies and pieces and
hey push forward it's a smooth it's a
smooth victory
right now um
and okay i mean the drawing chances are
not completely out of the woods
you know if you could get if you get
into a rook ending we know that those
are not always the easiest thing to
convert or even a queen ending
but no matter what ending it's a white
playing for two results because of this
extra pawn and dawn has some things to
figure out in the first date i mean just
if we're totally honest because he's
taken an approach that again
if you're just tuning in where have you
been robert's very angry with you that
you're late
but um john has not played his main line
stuff all day as white he's been rocking
a b3 system it's black he's been playing
you know some different kind of
sicilians so if he falls behind by two
games in the match what is the tipping
point where he's like all right
i got to win this thing it's time to go
for some main line theory here and use
my prep
i don't know if that moment will ever
come but i'm waiting for it
and i also want to mention that both
kings have some issues here
that the rook on e8 needs to stay there
otherwise a background check would be
devastating because of the
compromise dark squares around black's
king and for white your only outlet is
h2
but a timely bishop f4 could shake
things up so i i will say
that both kings need to be careful here
queen a4 takes a7 that looks
ideal but lavon looks great so far in
this match
no i agree good to highlight those
tactics those are things you got to be
aware of especially as time pressure
ensues
um but now
what do you play you probably bring the
queen no i was gonna say he probably
should have brought the queen back to
defend the rook something about this
move is not
not making uh the computer happy i'm
wondering is there some sort of tactic
yeah
it's back rank mate queen h4 hits h6 and
threatens rook d8
what look at you eating your wheaties
doing your puzzle rush and making mama
proud let's show it on screen
because we know she's watching hi mom
here we go
queen h4 bam slam
jam you move the bishop i don't care
where you put it doesn't matter
put that guy right there
i i mean you know oh we missed it like
we need four
probably still a very good move but yeah
i mean
okay look we see the position i was
talking about
the back rank idea so i already had it
in my head and it doesn't hurt but being
honest
doesn't hurt when you have the eval bar
being like
hey dude there's a win just make the
correct move
yeah this also eval barches coming to
you from
chess.com in 2021 it's on the product
roadmap i made eric do it
really yeah you're so proud of yourself
too that smile
that was a full-on i love it we'll call
it ludwig chess help chess i don't know
what we're going to call it yet but it's
coming and i think it's going to be a
really interesting variant because
you know what'll happen robert
psychologically you'll have players that
without eval chess robert are both 1800
but then when you add the eval bar one
of them is 2 000 and one of them is like
2 200 and what what might that suggest
about that player like
they lack confidence right it's a
psychological thing so i think there's
actually an instructive element
to playing chess as long as you remove
the eval we don't want the email or
announcing mate it's just the bar
telling you right i think that that's a
super interesting way to do it
and without like it's not fair if the
eval bar says hey you have mate and six
that's not what we're doing right but
just you know letting you know who's
better
both players so it'll be a lot of fun i
can't wait i have a very important
question for you first
question will i see queen h4 and find
that back rank mate and second question
do you think i will ever play eval chess
yes you will okay sure
whoa wait there's a pin down the d file
that was cool
whoa what's going on here
oh bishop takes f8 bishop of fate uh
bishop takes up
and you win the brook on b8 yeah
[Music]
lavon's winning yawn is cursing
great view into the man bun though he is
clearly letting his soul glow
back there right yes
but he's not very happy about what just
transpired because
yeah look at
well him should be and again i mean that
was a uh
it was a rough result he's now down by
two games after
after winning the first game not in the
match they drew the first but after
taking the first decisive game jan has
not
not been able to get a dub ever since
and is now down four to two
um and
wow where's the uh next game yeah so i'm
wondering what's going on with these
guys
where's the rematch two
went for a quick break now they're not
rematching
maybe they forgot how to rematch they
know how this works they've been doing
this for years
i'll check with the team
um hey someone named danny just
subscribed look at that
and it wasn't you what
says someone named danny just subscribed
and it wasn't you oh
cool here we go danny
there we go all right
we have liftoff um
shout out to all those of you still
playing guess the move we have a lot of
title players
indian lad given dragon b70 who normally
dominates a run for his money so that's
a lot of fun
if you don't know what guess the move is
go to chess.com
and play you can keep the show going
right don't leave us we want you here
with us
in fact sometimes our commentary might
even help you guess the right move
rarely at least mine not roberts let's
be honest
that guy um anyway but uh
open cash prizes playing against the
move robert for sure
we have our first e4 by john when
when you stopped talking about random
things that you know about i was going
to mention that
as soon as you shut the all right uh i
will shut the front door let's back up
to the analysis board and show
the opening jan has played 1b3 all day
not anymore he's down by two games i
said that he would switch back to main
line you said he wouldn't guess who was
right
wait when did i say that oh i did say
that you're right
admit it you heard that i said you were
right thank you and the position that we
have
on the board right now i didn't hear
what you said but
i could hear that you were mumbling
something trying to get past me what'd
you say
don't go drink your coffee what did you
say i didn't say anything
i was now you're lying to the whole all
right
queen night goodnight to f3 and yon is a
little better as white
better the positions that he's been
getting um
can i take the pawn though um
you can't but you drop b5 so it's an
interesting trade here
as black's pawn structure right now is
worse because black has these double
pawns
but that transition will give up your
essential e4 pawn
for one of the double pawns and leave
black with that isolated
queen pawn so it is a very interesting
choice here i think yan's position is
much easier to play
but don't count levon out here as if
he could open up the queen side he has a
bishop pair bishops work well
on both sides of the board in a way that
a knight doesn't because the knight is a
slower piece just in how it moves so
i think that the longer the this game
goes if the position can open up levon
has some chances but i really like
john's position out of the opening for
sure and well said and the long-term
features i think do favor black but i'm
i'm a little more skeptical of black's
king side maybe than
than you are at least and you sounded
because i don't know i just feel like
there's got to be some way to get
surgical up in this i mean lavon plays
f6
really a little worried i although it
does i guess it just stops knight g5 so
you know you start thinking of ways to
break through right ways to bring pieces
over to the side of the board
levon plays f6 to slow it down
but i think jan's response is very
instructional because
when your opponent has a bishop pair if
you can trade off
the bishop that you have for example now
take on b6 you have a knight
your opponent has a light square bishops
the dark squares are now yours so
if he does trade in fact there puts it
he's gonna put a knight on d4
and that knight can never be kicked out
of this beautiful central
square right a centralized knight
often just as good as a bishop even in
open positions and
john's gonna have quite the night on d4
but i like this move check cause he's
gonna he's gonna immediately go after
the d6 pawn i think
just put a rook on d1 yeah and here he
goes i think
i think yawn had had his enough of not
getting an advantage with the first move
and has gone back to some main line
openings and trying to get this back to
within the game
and his position is excellent he's up a
clean pawn he's much better here
but i do think lavonda the best thing
that he possibly could
is he gave up the pond well he didn't
have a choice at that point but still
sometimes you give up a pawn
to try to get full development and look
what he's done he has made white's king
a little bit weaker
he has made that pawn structure on white
king's head compromised
and white's dominating there's no
questions about that
but he's giving himself chances as this
game continues yup
i'm yupping you right now yeah i know
and i didn't like it
i haven't gotten to yup someone in a
while you just got yupped
um you're you're not a yuppie but you
wish you were
um e5 has been played yawn shook his
head there i'm curious why i think he's
still
better right it looks it looks kind of
smooth and
i did want to back up and just you know
with our jokes aside it was such an
instructive point robert highlighted
with bishop g4
because so many people will will die
trying to defend bad positions but this
is the practical thing
you want to start to develop in your
chess game recognize when things have
gone wrong
right you give yourself these practical
chances that you wouldn't otherwise have
and i think that even if you know
white is up a pawn and obviously yawn is
better in a blitz game
where your opponent you know doesn't
always have a lot of time you've opened
your opponent's king and those are the
kind of practical chances you might need
although as i say you don't have a lot
of time look at yon's time compared to
lavon's
uh this is what we've seen pretty much
every game is yawn with the lead on the
clock not this much though
this is as bad as it gets for lavon
because this is
it kind of reminds me of classical chess
honestly where you've played a long game
now you're down
into a position that's better for white
but you're hoping to survive as black
but you have no time
and you just have spent too much in the
earlier stages
yeah but i i would
love to just like keep your pawns double
than the f file but i know that if i
move my rook from e8 to f8 for example
there could be some
f5 and whose king is weaker at that
point it looks like blacks but maybe
what
it can be turned around and white's king
could get some trouble so he does just
that
i don't know yeah i'm with you it's it
ended up being a weird double-edged
finish with both kings open and the
major pieces on the board double death
bonds are not the the prettiest thing to
look at
so i guess from lavon's defensive point
of view if he can just kind of sit tight
maybe he has better drawing chances even
just in the rook ending
yes i'll put queen of six i guess i had
a necessity just more than anything like
i said get to the rook ending
yeah and those pawns are bad and if you
look at the queenside pawns
it's a three on three on the queen side
despite the fact that black's pawns are
doubled
and on the king side you don't really
have a passport
the way you would like but that's a good
move rook d7 yeah this was instructive
everybody because what john's saying is
exactly to prove me and robert wrong
if you take i will take with the pawn
and now i'm doing now i'm looking fancy
and feeling fancy
you sure are vaseline yeah this this is
a good move you maintain the tension try
to get black to take and fix your
structure
how is the king of pawn in the game
though like if rook f7 can you oh he
doesn't play vertical seven because
it won't happen now but that's an
interesting question
and okay so how to go forward from here
you can trade on f6 and take on b7
but that will only be one extra pawn in
a rook end game
and those are notorious for being
uh giving the side that's down upon
great drawing chances so
i don't know if he wants to take on f6
here and he has plenty of time
so i would advise using some of it right
you would advise john to use it you and
every coach that he's had since his
childhood
and you know what he said to a lot of
those coaches i don't need time
i'm young upon machine um
and guess what he didn't need to take
his time he just went for the queen c7
he's probably right yes because after
queen f4
and that's why we have rook h8 which is
a very sad move to play yeah he could
have
taken on h7 then traded queens and then
taken on b7 two extra pawns in the rook
in the game
should suffice let's just from a
practical point of view everybody i'll
applaud yon real quick that
regardless of the fact that he's
criticized sometimes we're playing too
fast when you have this kind of time
it often is wise to just keep the
position as
is don't give any clarity right because
the easiest moves for your opponent to
play are the forcing moves the
recaptures
when you check they just move right so
keep the position
look at yep and oh he made that move but
the point is
a lot harder to play this position with
no time
and indeed he converts because of it so
i think
even if the the queen trader rook ending
was winning this was the right decision
by yon and he's brought it back to
within a game as he takes a sip of that
t
i think that's a very good point danny
that you made there is
when your opponent has mere seconds on
the clock and you are well ahead
we're half joking when we say take your
time because there are moments
in classical games as well where young
plays too quickly and it backfires
but it is in those moments where you are
pressuring your opponent on the board
and on the clock you don't want to
simplify allow them several quick moves
and that gives them the ability to
figure out the position hey danny we
have
your favorite opening mine is i was just
going to say after applauding yawn's
last game i have to
turn my nose in disgust
but you know you like these lines way
more than most of the others
yeah these lines are exciting though
this is the poison pond
right this is what i'm this is what i'm
all about um
the winner and the poison pawn not seen
at the highest levels
every day anymore it was all the rage in
the in the 90s but
we'll do back up real quick just set the
tone of what this french is all about
ooh because h4 i haven't seen that one
in a while
oh boy the widower is defined with this
move bishop b4 in the french the basic
dynamic quickly is that black will get
positional
advantages on the queen side in exchange
for having parted ways with his dark
square bishop
the white immediately exposes that with
things like queen g4
and in these variations uh the main line
after knight bc6
is actually to play the move f4 to
protect e5
and then bring the queen back um but
yawn plays h4
not the most commonly traveled road and
now queen d3 the risk of these lines is
that e5 falls
but what white's saying in these
variations is look
i even if i'm not up upon i still have
a past pawn right so in a lot of the
poison pawn white is trying to keep that
pawn which is why it's called the poison
pond here white gave it back
you're gonna win c3 and try to just win
on the dark squares you'll notice that
there's
no variation of the french robert that i
don't like for white
i even like this i like the main line
poison pawn and i like this
this is a much sharper variation
compared to others yeah
and i think i need to do myself a favor
and give my good friend tatsu abrahamian
a phone call
she exclusively plays the french and
uh the amount of winners she's had in
her career
but she would like yawn's position here
and as much as i i got my
you know i got my punches in i like
white in every variation the more i'd
look at this position i'm like yawn
uh he went with the frenchy dirty dog
but why do you live on play
h4 i mean the main lines are the main
lines are good enough you don't got to
go for that but just
play the main line you know what it
could be danny and
as amazing as a player as lavon is of
course
sometimes when you play openings that
you don't play
regularly you make mistakes in the early
theory
and you forget i do think that the
position's still playable but you play
move like h4 you're like wait was that
the right time to do that or am i now
allowing black to just get a good
position
yup you okay there you i think you're
frozen because you're just so displeased
at the french
so i'm just pleased with the position
while i got here
don't forget your lines and then i can
forgive you right
i forget but never forgive that's how
that's supposed to go i'm pretty sure to
forgive is divine
i don't remember but you get it you hold
a mean grudge look at you
yeah but you know what's interesting
about this danny is
like what is black's plan black's pieces
are perfectly placed
are you just gonna go e4 e3 are you
gonna like do something like that to me
you're gonna push your pawns
black has so many good plans in these
positions this is the problem with the
white side of the poison pond is this
king is never safe
black gets safe but the castle is long
so when you've allowed the center to be
you know not even just undermined here
just you know taken by black
this is super tough for for white
because even exchange sacks are always
on the agenda and you have these end
games where the e pawn is super strong
um i like your idea of e4 and e3
in fact i love that idea as much as i
hate saying that
i just feel like what's going right for
white and the answer might be
nothing yeah the only thing that's
that's right is harry over here you're a
wizard we'll see if he can pull
something magical
out of his you-know-what but i don't
think so i think i think yawn is going
to tie this match and by the way
will we get one more five minute game
let's look at the clock
oh i didn't even think about that i
feel like we'll get one more after this
that's my guess what just happened there
bishop e4 was a blunder
and that must be why pawn was hanging
oh my gosh i still like black forget it
but well
knight's coming to c4 though
oh that's the fork that he missed he was
threatening a fork of the king and
bishop
okay what is happening here so you can
play rook h2
or rook g1 i don't know which is better
but that's something that needs to be
figured out
i'm like something tells me those
playing guess the move in this game
robert are not going to get a very high
percentage
this is not indian he's playing and so
is dragon b70 so you know
knight to c4 okay he's just giving up h1
to go knight d6 check
and take b7 well you can also just take
a5
true too much to think about
damn my head hurts you didn't pay me for
this yeah this is
this is a head hurting position um
yawn does have a little more time to
think it through whether he uses it or
not is always the question
um would you
go so far say this is a pretty critical
moment of the entire match
because it's a one point lead for lavon
and
yeah you're right knight takes a five
just looks good
especially because yawn had just won
that last game right so if lavon
immediately responds
and maintains a two-game lead i think
that in a match that we expect is going
to come down to the wire and bullet
you and i say this a lot right this is
this is a
a moment where we won't be talking about
this one as much as the bullet because
it's always you know what you remember
last right but these moments here could
be just as deciding to the match as as
what happens in the end
knight takes a5 was played and uh
i like aronian's position the french
will go down
i don't hear anything uh oh
we have disconnections
we have robert here
we lose internet
oh i can
robert yeah that's on you guys
it's our internet
wait now you're back i think maybe
are the players legit fine
oh they're fine and we're back wow and
now i hear you again
and everyone heard us the whole time
if you guys didn't see my face i have my
oh face and i also have my your god is
my live server crashing
fake um but it doesn't look like it is
that was uh that was strange
well uh you know maybe
what's going on mickey recipes danny but
i will take
awkward chess broadcast moments for 400
please
awkward just broke he once made it
awkward just so he could say he knew how
it feels
who said that diana naraditsky but also
the most interesting man in the world
yeah um
okay f3 played by lavon and still
looks to be good i guess he's up the
exchange but this is not
an exchange where you know you're
converting
easily right robert this is uh
especially with only 30 seconds on the
clock this is a really weird position
it is but let's do a you know there's an
extra exchange the h
pawn that's a clear passer and the
bishop on h1 is such a problematic piece
and oh there's some knight d4 ideas oh
very nice oh my gosh wait you could take
on e2 and then go knight d4 check
but i don't know if you can catch the h
pawn oh the h
pawn to the batcave let's show it the
analysis board it turns out harry is a
wizard
and if you go for this you can't stop me
oh wait you can
play bishop takes e5 before we should be
five first freaking
sick if that doesn't highlight the the
bishop's dominance over a knight
nothing will so yawn can't that's
that's really nasty everybody i mean d3
this was a wild wild idea here by lavon
to allow queen takes e2 because of the h
pawn so
if he goes on to win this game it might
be because of that tactic but look at
look at
depot he's keeping it yeah he
managed to make his way back in this one
here and
even the pressure yeah i think levon's
time trouble is really costing him at
this moment because
uh it seemed like he was in good shape
levant threw excuse me jan threw in that
check
and caught levon probably off guard a
bit
and now that bishop one h1 is alive and
well and yeah
actually quite a strong piece whoa in
fact now he's just giving back the
exchange
practically a draw for obscure bishops
yeah that's what you call a decision
made because of time trouble as right
under 20 seconds he's like i don't want
to risk this let me just
force this into an equal position
yeah rook takes e5 was saying i feel
like this is a game that i'm going to
lose in the time scale
and maybe not the worst practical
decision right they are human beings
after all
not just computers and
i think now yawn is making that decision
do i want to keep the time scramble
alive try to swindle myself something
with only 16 seconds
or do i just take the draw
nope he wants to swing five i'm pushing
that pawn
push him baby there's just no mating
net that black can come true here i just
yeah the problem for yawn is like how do
you actually make tricks because the
queen defends the bishop
very hard for me to make a blunder here
right
queen's defensive bishop bishop defends
the queen right i mean unless i
walk into mate there's no blunders
coming
yeah i mean i was blunderful with my
vocabulary it's a construe and i was
like what am i talking about i might
configure it but anyway vocabulary
what'd you say
no don't worry about it danny don't
worry about it anyway so
this looks like a offer a piece note
that the eight
pawn the a1 square does not match
black's bishop
so all white needs to do is trade off
the bishop for the b-bond to force his
driver i hope that's what he does
or is it just sack and then put the king
here
yeah that's what he should do he's a
draw
and this will officially be the last
game of the five minute portion it took
a long time and he does it
yes robert has his dreams are alive
there they are for those tuning in we
got
10 000 of you on twitch and about 5 000
on youtube
thanks for being here you didn't know
this was a draw the reason is that the
bishop
can't force the king out of the opposite
color corner so it doesn't matter what
you have even when you win the pawn
you cannot win an end game with a wrong
color corner bishop
even with an extra pawn and and minor
piece so fun fact if you didn't know
robert i stole your thunder there um
i'll forgive you eventually but we we
have a one game match
and we'll check in with what our smarter
chess predictions said in a minute
and uh see what we think uh will happen
as these two players face the faster
segments today but right now we have our
next primetime smackdown coming up
um i don't even remember who it was if
this is my match versus john bartholomew
or john's match versus eric rose we've
had a lot of these going on they've been
a ton of fun
but um if it's my match versus
bartholomew you are in for a treat
i'm gonna say that um if it's frozen and
bartholomew it's probably lame you
should probably leave right now let's be
honest those guys
not rocking the the biggest personality
stuff
am i still on air okay let's go to break
[Music]
all right john you want to start us off
hey guys this is john and
my uh semi-annual beatdown of
international master danny wrench
vice president of chess.com happy to be
here with you today oh man that's
hilarious
okay i was giving you the opportunity
hey guys i mean off the camera i already
told
everybody i told the team that's
recording this that i would rather take
black first just to avoid your damn
scandinavian
okay and what i said in reply is you
don't have to play e4
well i'm going to we'll see what happens
in the match
okay like you said all right anyway john
great to see you man and uh here we go
this is gonna be a ton of fun
um be gentle all right
just kidding don't be gentle best of
five one minute let's do this
levy the other day told so told me that
somebody paid him to keep the match
close i was like whatever dude
that's not even true when did you
start playing the tory i mean or the the
you haven't been paying attention to my
games over the past couple years
it has been a while since we played
hasn't it been it has we used to do
chess rivals and then some
yup yup which was
a ton of fun agreed i would say we
should bring that back but i've got
enough pain in my life why would i put
myself in that
um yeah what are you doing we already
have
like three kids so i don't know if i
need a kid in my life
yeah possible adoption again wouldn't
that be
uh oops yeah that was a bishop wasn't it
you didn't see it
i'll take it can i do this i'm doing it
oh okay don't know what's going on but
i'm doing it
sharp stuff hey not the first time that
i've uh
wait i think that actually worked i i
definitely thought that rook was
defended on d1
not gonna lie to you guys okay
so did i um
but hmm
i'll take it what are you doing
don't do things
i'm gonna lose this first no clean sweep
no clean sweep
nice i mean i'm just
i'm i'm with you and how shocked you
feel right now
my heart goes after you your strategy of
giving me white in the first game is
already paid
psychologically i avoided the
scandinavian beatdown now
now i'm gonna play d4 and if somehow
that leads to a victory i put you in a
where a lot of people are against
against me which is just you know all
you have to do is win a few games it's
not that hard against me
there you go oh that's a good point
though i have my back against the wall
already
yeah you have my back against the walls
have you said
i was saying my back but all right here
we go
i i told you before we started uh i
don't know if this is gonna air
i'm not in charge of the production but
if this airs before the match with levy
if you will know i almost beat levy in a
match twist
i'm the i'm literally the almost didn't
almost doesn't count guy you have to
keep reminding him of that
what is going on here driving me crazy
with your good moves
yeah you're the guy who like nearly won
the state championship
ball
oh my gosh what did you do what are you
doing
i was oh man why did you pre-move that
i don't know i don't know what you were
doing
dude ah mine okay this is the scenario
we didn't want
dude this is the this has never happened
to me i gotta i gotta replay it how did
that happen
how did what did you do with the
pre-move
let's see knight knight d2 queen d3
knights
knight e4 yeah i played knight d1
out of pure desperation defense and you
pre-moved rook c3
i guess i didn't predict that you would
play a move that bad i know
[Music]
so
and we are back here the speed chess
championship rolls on
as do all of the guests of movers this
is a snapshot of the last game of the
five minute portion we saw dragon b70
overtake grand master indian lad
but will it be the money game remember
when the entire match is over we
randomly choose one of the games that
has been played throughout the whole day
so you have not missed your chance yet
and just because there are others on the
leaderboard before you literally gives
them
no more chance than you to win the cash
prizes or the premium memberships
just fun to see all the different title
players playing so head over
play guess the move uh try to learn some
chess from yondu palm machine lavon
ironian
and maybe win some cash along the way
speaking of yonder palm machine levon
roni and robert
smarter chess predictions actually did
have lavon taking the edge in the 5 1
portion
not quite by by two games but if
if that stays the course then yawn is
about to bounce back here
yeah and lavon you know he was kind of
close to making it
a two-game spread but lavon extremely
young held well
there in the end and i must say smart
chess doing a decent job
but john is favoring the quicker time
patrols
and if these predictions hold true then
john's in great shape to win this match
as he is
only down one game as we head into three
minute plus one second increment
time segment yama 3-2 in the twitch chat
that's an interesting
request that we've actually gotten
multiple times the problem with how
allowing multiple move like pre-moves
while you're playing guess the move
is a lot of times you guess the move and
then you maybe change your mind before
they've moved and so you need to click
and go away so it's not exactly easy to
build in
multiple guesses built up like we allow
for multiple premiums when you're
playing guess the move so
i saw that same request earlier in chess
tv so i'm acknowledging it
but i don't know if it's something that
is actually possible to do so
anyway but appreciate you playing and
appreciate the request appreciate nine
thousand plus of you
on twitch we've still got six thousand
of you over on youtube right now
the party has just begun i think we're
in for a nail biter and here we go
the three minute is about to start we
have liftoff
and let's see young gets the white
pieces will there it is e4
so he realizes this whole b3 stuff
not working out for him in this oh oh no
we have berlin stuff going on but this
is fun last time
oh now we've got a a very
open game here for black this is a you
know we always call d3 the ante berlin
not because it actually
that's not the actual name of it but it
avoids the main line theory and
gives robert hope for the future of life
so we love that we love the auntie
berlin robert's not a big berlin guy
look at how theoretical this line is
it's really hard to
get everything acknowledged but if we
just take a quick look with an analysis
board
after black made the ninth move castle
um it looks like a5 just traps the
bishop on b6
because that was the whole point of
white's play was it not to go a5
and trap it but i believe that there's
like a bishop takes f2 check and
e4 move like it's a very complicated
position and i don't know all the ins
and outs i just know that
black is not giving away a piece for
free yeah the crazy line the king is
forced to walk directly into the face of
danger here
and um not something
that that white likes so knight bd2 is
played instead
still a5 is a possibility but yawn
declines it yet again to play bishop a3
which threatens things like b5 so these
guys
know their theory e4 is played anyway
and with the position opening up
in the end the trade frees the bishop
that you're not losing it but white is a
little bit better probably in the end
game
i guess because of the the d-pawn but
maybe not actually wait i mean
things over here that are falling yeah
yeah
i think most of the high-level games
that have played this line have just
resulted
in a draw surprise surprise
but white does look a bit better in
terms of pawn structure because if you
look at the d6 pawn
that's more weakness but it's not really
going to amount to much if i remember
correctly ray robson
essayed this opening against wesley so
in the u.s championship recently
concluded
championship so um not all that much
happening in terms of novel ideas at
this point
yeah i wish i would say about this i did
refill my coffee if you're wondering
i was deeply curious
anyway all right so 95 is a trade of
d-pawn for c-pawn potentially
um the weird position because normally
this this whole queen side expansion is
all aggressive for white and and this
king is
you know resting on the king side but
not not the case in this
line um it's starting to look bad for
white
yeah i'm sorry like black it's a
beautiful square and then
you just took a pawn so yep what's
john's idea here
yon gives the old you know we call that
yonder pop
yonda pandushi head nod number four
and what does that tell us besides you
know flaunting that means i know i'm
worse but
i'm already here might as well keep
playing chess i actually say that's a
pretty accurate assessment of his head
bob
and then that's diana palmer and she
look over the shoulder number seven
pretending like there's something that i
heard but that's just because i'm bored
and i don't like to think of my
opponent's clock
you want me to keep translating every
facial expression
well lavon hasn't really had too many
facial expressions so we're you know
yacht is the only place you can go
i think you're doing a great job all
right well black is better here jokes
aside i mean and right now if lavonne
stole that pawn
and white doesn't get it back then
then uh bond is a pawn right
um here do not take on e3 because the
knight will recapture with
a fork on the rooks but what you can do
is play rook to e1
and if the bishop takes on c1 then you
can consider
taking on e8 and taking this knight on
c4 so you can transition
instead of having the same pieces in the
end game you can say i like the
prospects of my knight
more than your dark sport bishop yeah
and he goes for that
we might see it on the board nope
lavonne recognizes that
the end game is let's analyze that real
quick because robert's line was was
instructive one of those
rare times where you could actually go
into an end game up a pawn and be worse
you know with white's king being so
active the d-pawn being weak
i would i would think that white is
doing well here um although
maybe black house counter plays so
either way lavonne doesn't like the
transition he plays rookie six
maintaining the steering contest here on
e3 and c1
and i think lavon is you know he's
put himself in another good spot i
agree with you and g2 is now under
attack uh there is
some difficulty here if you take on g2
then once the rook capturing e6 the
d-pawn
would have been hanging but now the
knight on c4 protects that pawn
which i think is a very good decision by
lavon here but a5 is a nice response by
yon
yeah i i like the way that yawn is
playing this even though he's a little
worse because if there's
any misstep there's any slight wrong
transition
like maybe what we're seeing now these
advanced pawns if we get like a quick
trade
suddenly become aggressive you know
aggressive potential new queens so you
have to be really careful if you're
erroneous
he's up a pawn but it's a weak d6 pawn
but levon's actually handling this
excellently and i think that
you wanted to boot this knight from c4
but somehow it remains a thorn in yon's
side here
a6 just to not hang your a7 pawn d6 is
protected by that very knight on c4
so levon's extra pawn would live yeah
h5 okay about equal on the clock so the
three minute portion not revealing
anything yet
so knight comes e5 now this f7 pawn if
it wants can go to f5 but i wouldn't do
that because
you should look at your base pawns where
could the weaknesses be
if i push f7 then g6 becomes looser so
that's why
the f pawn will remain where it is
keeping the pawn gene
good point watch out for forks
he avoids that and now you
would like to keep the 95 but you'd also
like to move it out of the way to the
rook
and watch out for b5 check at some point
there could be like a fork in the air
if if take everything you get a fork on
c7 and if you back up there's a fork on
f6 so
lavon now under the clock trying to
solve this problem did you miss b5
no it wouldn't i think he did it was
king c5 there was always king c5 just
keeping
uh you safe there okay
you have to watch out here all right
only a few seconds knight f6 check
is in the air okay couldn't couldn't get
away with it
so but now black is defending passively
so you're up a pawn but
your pawns are kind of weak and you're
in passive position
yep and you only have a few seconds that
night is tricky
it is indeed night is tricky
e6 that could be a move that pushes too
far though for yon because now
now you've deadlocked things and your
pawns are also very weak
i agree
and he missed it oh and
i don't know what john said but it
wasn't pg
oh man and again he's just shaking his
head oh
wow that was painful
yeah that that that wasn't good
it felt like b6 was pushing a little too
far
honestly it felt like he should have
settled on
the fact that he had been worse most of
the game down a pawn acknowledge what
was so
and and keep the tension like the moment
we bring up the analysis board the
moment he played b6
i was just like ah that's how good
positions you go a little too far i
think because
you know you had all the tension here
you could have just repeated with a draw
they'd already repeated once
but instead he plays the move b6
and lets the king come up and now it was
white who was really full of targets
lavon
did not have to be asked twice to grab
the g file
and even even if he doesn't blunder the
exchange like he's already i mean 93
check is coming and night see
i mean just to show robert there was
like awkwardness like this right with
mates
i mean this was advancing those pawns
was not a good idea and he pays the
price
yeah you actually called it completely
when you said hey this b6 move that's it
and
it's in this notion of a backward pawn
the pawn a5 quickly became a target
and much easier to attack when you
release the tension
and it's a good lesson in tension as
well but right now danny
we do have a french i actually like
black's position i don't really
think that white is breaking through
anytime soon and
if that's the case look down that c file
look at those double c
pawns and also the f5 square it's a
light square you only have a dark square
bishop
so if that knight can quickly get to f5
if you could put the knight right now at
f5 black would be in great shape
yeah let's bring up the analysis board
to show where levon varied if you're
just joining us the last game of the
five minute portion was the same exact
position
in the traditional widower lavon went
for the main line with queen g4
in this game he played seven h4 which is
a line uh not as not as well known
um but ultimately dawn seemed prepared
for it
defends against the rushing h-pawn and
then what happens is if white fails to
deliver anything on the missing dark
square
bishop which is kind of the overarching
theme of the winower
then it's only a matter of time before
you're positionally worse on the queen
side as robert said and so
i'm kind of with you this doesn't look
like a line that had a lot of bite
it's still always double-edged because
forever you have the potential dark
squares if you're white
but i'm with you that in a rare in a
rare sense that almost never comes out
of my mouth
i like this position for black in the
french and look at that move after queen
g3
g7 most of us react oh my pawn's under
attack let me protect it
but there were tactical flaws in
protecting it with sacrifices so he puts
in 97
defends it tactically rather than
directly because knight coming to f5
just like we talked about danny that's a
light square you have a dark square
bishop
you cannot kick this night out this is a
great position for yon
i agree i think i think yawn is maybe
finding the opening he's going to keep
playing for because
even though that poison pawn got weird
and maybe lavon was better right i mean
jan had a good position there
lavon clearly not on the cutting edge of
his theory here on the white side of
these of these winnowers
i mean not no no you know offense
intended but at least in terms of the
lines he's been choosing this is not
positions we've liked for white oh not
at all because
whether or not you keep these double c
pawns on the board or you trade on d4
and open up the c file
for your rook and queen to barrel down
black's position looks quite safe
there are no weaknesses the knight on f5
is so strong
not only attacking the d4 square but
defending g7
pretty much permanently and the rook on
g4 kind of needs to share the square
with a pawn
can't do that sorry not allowed and if
that's the case then
black should be able to uh get it out of
this and here comes queen c4 isn't trade
questions
you just invented a new variant share
the square
sharing is caring cheer the square
share the square no but i know many
times i've wanted to share the square of
my life
like you you you said it so well you
want the pawn to kick the knight but but
you actually don't want the pawn there
because then you want to move it back
and have the rook here
right so share the square somebody
called my agent
i don't have an agent oh yeah that's
right back to the game
queen c4 all right
um yeah lavonne is definitely on the
worst side of this french
um the rook comes up the d-pawn's weak
this is the opposite of what the
potential of your dark square bishop is
and
on the white side of a winter world this
is now you're just you know
you're staring at uh you're staring at
hot air right there's nothing to do with
these squares this king is going to come
up the rook joins the queen side
the great position for black yeah and
the one thing that
black really does need to be careful
about is not moving the king away and
allowing g4 because the f7
pawn does need some defense but a
typical move thematic idea is
g5 or g6 here for black saying your pawn
h5 is a huge thorn in my side
so let me push through and try to
actually open up the
side because my pieces are ready to
start countering
okay well he goes g4 unfortunately he
will not be sharing the square
we have not invented that yet but
but lavonne is is trying to prove us
wrong and say wait a second guys there's
some long-term features here my bishop
does eventually find a purpose
i still believe i don't care what
computers say i mean i feel like this is
a position that only black can win
uh because of the weaknesses because of
the the french structure
um but i will admit it's become a little
tricky for black robert because
you can't quite coordinate without the f
palm being weak
this and if you can't do that robert
then the rook is out of play so this is
a little bit tricky right here
yeah and i would say one big idea for
white is to play a5 at the right moment
to open up the queen side
and if you respond to a5 to keep the
position closed b5
then white thrusts that pawn to a6 yeah
and leaves the a7 pawn
stuck on a dark square where it can be
attack later but nope that's not
happening
for sure probably that lavon is four
seconds
what oh we've been blocked in the world
of chess
we forgot we got other problems here one
second
oh boy you gotta play c3 and then hope
for the draw right defense so
if there was something there he clearly
didn't have the time to press lavon is
officially back where we thought he'd be
which is
fighting for a draw on this worst end
game in the french and
now f6 you that's the move your yawn
it is a thematic move it's a strong move
it tries to chisel the center
but also in your opponent's time trouble
very hard to meet
yep yeah and as a latest says in the
chess tv chat it's important to note
that
yawn chose the french and the candidates
he did but he also got smashed by mbl
in the french in the candidates so that
was probably not a good decision of the
candidates i wasn't going to bring that
up
but i'm glad you did because it's good
to remind people that just because he
did it doesn't mean he remembers it
doesn't mean it's although i think i
think he may keep going to it today
lattice and chess tv so you're not wrong
but in the candidates a little bit
different
um i think he's going to get this one
though this is so tricky for white rook
c4
you got to run you have to play a5 for
white i think it's your only chance
look at that b5
bring the rook back this is not the same
position where you have a dark square
bishop going after the pawn
but it's not so easy for black to win i
know that he's well on the clock but
lavon's doing
a really good job here like props to him
if he can get
an attack on the a7 pawn he could even
turn this thing around not going to
happen
and think about it oh rook b2 now
yeah nice king f1 oh or losing time
on uh the time pressure finally caught
up with him
what was the final evaluation of that
position i mean i know black was better
but if we bring it up we've got
king f1 how does black win you just
trade on g2
and then probably yeah
yeah i guess so that's actually okay
back to the current game
and and back to some main line theory by
the way
uh plays he plays d6 this time around
rather than the d5 line yeah
although that might be because jan
castle right in the other game the king
didn't castle so it's
these slight move order changes
that can be very confusing for most
players myself included
and well what's happened so e4 is
hanging that's why he did this and
now he protected e5
wow danny what do you make of this
opening knights in g6 we don't really
love them often
but maybe we're a little too harsh
we're a little too harsh on those nights
yeah
during those donkeys a night in front of
a g or a b-pawn loses his cred
he's back to a donkey no but jokes aside
in this structure it's not going to mean
it's not going to stay this way that's
black's whole idea you're building up
a transition to open the position and
you need all the pony support
you can get um
it's not quite the same i'm sorry i was
distracted by the live chest chat i'm
always
i always love when members tune in
because people who watch these shows
think oh like how does everyone not know
the sec is going on people tune in like
let's go why are so many people watching
this game is this a tournament or
something
and somebody else is like yeah i think
they're playing for like a thousand
bucks
just awesome i love that the chess world
is so big
people don't give a crap about this show
and i mean i'm looking now at the chat
as well i see the indian lad
still crushing it yeah still crushing it
would guess the move
um all right so the transition
in the center happens in these italian
games
i think we're going to have a little bit
you know for those who tuned in early
enough to see that yawn was avoiding
theories white
time to start getting your notebooks out
if you're one of the more advanced
players watching the show because
my guess is they are engaging now in
some much more relevant theory
but beyond mine and robert's you know
level of chess prep these days i'll say
that
but this doesn't look very good for uh
for one
like you've just given up the bishop
pair okay bishop g6 trademarks
what oh look at the f takes that was
essential and maybe
that's what i i didn't see that coming
and that's clearly what yon missed
yeah because oh man go ahead no yo you
finished the sentence what was i'm on
the edge of my seat let's analyze go
ahead
yeah the point was you took with the h
pawn right then queen the a check comes
in
and you're all tied down you're all out
of sorts back here i wouldn't even take
on d4 i just my knight c4
bring my knight towards your king and
try to mate you with an eventual knight
g5 check right you're just
that's such an instructive point and i
think as you said that's what john
missed because when lavon took here you
could see he paused
and levon's idea i guess was just queen
of f8 right right
and then the bishop pair reigned supreme
over the nights
robert you're so good at teaching chess
i mean you almost sound like you were
saying it sarcastically as if there's no
child talking to you
accidental teaching moment by robert
hess
um rookie i do love that i appreciate it
no announcements bishops
exactly dirty dog bishops look at queen
of four
oh no okay the brook was hanging but i
was i was trying to figure out a way to
threaten mate and defend the bishop and
attack the knight but okay
what do you see sex just getting into a
slightly better ending but i don't
actually don't think this is
as much as you would hope for it's
better for black but
probably not on the cusp of winning like
in some of the other
lines that if yon and misplayed he would
have ventured into by mistake
yeah probably we're just headed toward
equality
two well bishop takes e3
okay that's a really good move because
you're you're at least
causing your opponent a little bit of
stress with that isolated pawn but
i think ultimately you're right danny
just repeat
you know you know what's frustrating
danny is that earlier f takes g6 was
necessary
but in that final position you really
wish you were h takes g6 right
yeah you have in fact let's bring up the
the analysis board just to show what
robert's talking about the main point is
that if you just
in the final position if you just flip
the script of these pawns
black actually has very decent winning
chances because this
this pawn is not only is it not passed
anymore
meaning it's not a pawn that can run to
a queen for those who don't speak french
a past pawn
has nobody who can stop him this would
make that not a past pawn but it also
would mean that
that the pawn is a bigger weakness right
than it is now
so interesting point that f takes jesus
because you said robert was necessary
and ultimately limited winning chances
that uh often is the case i feel like
but whoa so g2 hanging but bishop e4
would be the resp
what's what is this wait what
a g2 okay so he's just saying the bishop
pair is
going to overwhelm you that's all he's
getting is the bishop pair as far as
comp goes he's down a pawn
look but he's so much development both
bishops that knight coming to b5
grook one happening castling queen side
this could just be a knockout
lavon i feel like why i feel like he
surprises me so often in the opening
where it goes things like this and then
he's just
i don't know i i haven't seen this
opening
this position in any other scc match yet
this year robert that's what i'm saying
i feel like it's just
kind of a newer opening and lavon's
about to
maybe stretch this thing back to a
two-game lead
his position looks excellent it's just
so many ideas are clear
for lavon with the white pieces whereas
john my ideas for black are
defensive knight a6 has stopped the fork
on c7 he plays it
but now i see rook g1 you can't castle
because then i can take your knight in
f6 and your g pawn
he gives up the g pawn but that can't
just give it back
yeah i'm taking it again everybody
castles would have allowed all to show
the quick tactic no analysis board
needed just show real quick
pin it to win it but yeah so white is
better you can even castle long here
keep the pressure
i like it and what's he thinking about
so
castling queen side he's not going to
take on f6 at least not yet
oh he might have some kind of knight d6
because the knight f6 isn't protected
so like like that hits f7
it sort of forces a king takes d6 maybe
and then
oh he does it robert yeah playing guess
the move bro what you can do at
chess.com right now win cash prizes and
premium memberships
that's the move by robert hess i love
that
you should always be looking at hanging
pieces and the knight on f6 is only
defended by the king
so knight d6 in a sense it's a protected
square because you may give up your
knight when you win your opponent's
knight and then knight f6 is a crucial
defender for the black king
oh it's a nathan f34r mod mod's working
hard thanks for all the support
instantly as soon as i did that little
rant i was going to guess the move
yes the move command um
yeah that's an awesome move robert jokes
aside i mean seriously good find
it's just one of those positions danny
from as soon as
black went up a pawn and we were
highlighting how white had more
development
i start immediately thinking okay i'm
down material which he is no longer down
material but i start thinking about
tactics because
right the black king is never going to
find shelter so let me try to go for
for it all oh yikes
if you can't get a free sub boiling
you can just throw us your twitch prime
and watch the twitch
primetime smackdown right aptly named
you're missing it i'm currently engaged
in a match with john bartholomew at the
break find out who wins
subscribe to the twitch channel um all
right yeah white's crushing it let's
bring up the analysis board
uh because you you highlighted the
opening i think lavon is just
brushing it here we were also talking
about the end of that rook ending but
again lavonne goes away for the first
time everybody from the mainline winter
wars and i just wanted to highlight
because it's part of the match storyline
is these guys
you know improve and show the show the
high level footwork of how they're
adjusting
so he goes away from the mainline win
awards we've seen e5 in every other game
but he goes with bishop d3 and clearly
got yawn in some sideline he wasn't
ready for because this
grab on g2 was not a good idea and as
robert has said white is just
crushing in development and as we catch
up to the live game
currently crushing in the live position
as well um
just awesome awesome chess here and
lavon might be about to jump back up by
two games
and he's up two pawns at this moment so
he started down one
that means he's taken three pawns in the
process
of achieving this position here and
all right black has some chances because
white's pawn on the king side
they're isolated and pawns are best
pushed with a pawn next to it because
the strongest pawn is one protected by
its buddy right because
you have to use a more valuable piece to
attack it so that's the problem that
white is facing
but lavon is doing extremely well in the
clock danny that is
a new thing that we haven't seen much of
yeah we
we just saw several people in chat all
chats pointing that out
uh zen ottoman and the chess tv chat
rocking that premium membership i gave
you from just a couple matches ago
because it's understandable for yon to
not want to play as candidates prep but
against aronian you know can he really
do that
um i think he has switched into some
mainline stuff now and i think he'll
continue to fight
be willing to play mainline stuff here
on out
ronian converting
sorry it was a chicken spammers from the
chat you know just
you were what everyday fun i was kicking
spammers from the chat so that's why i
love that
when you moderate it gets me going i'll
tell you what you're moderating robert
hess is playing mod rolls
all right you cross the line you know
usually you're
i don't know what's going on with me
today the accents have taken over
oh man it's so good yeah that
i no look at that he leaves the king on
the c
file so that the c2 pawn isn't hanging
perfection
push up maybe push him baby yeah i was
thinking that too can you just push the
pawn he's heat
lavon he's so practical he's like i'm
not even giving you any counter play
h pawn will win the game later on he
maintains a two-game lead
and i say maintains because he was up
two points jan struck back
and now lavon regains that margin
but now young's gone back into something
weird no longer the uh
the e4 italian game we've been seeing
but to be fair
it wasn't even just because uh you know
doesn't want to play main lines or
something he wasn't getting anything as
white right in the italian there that
last game
lavon played on the black side of the
italian was good for him
so and
yeah this again has the carro con like
pawn structure with an exchange white
has given up the e
pawn for black's c pawn and it looks
like that happened on the d5 square
right
but in these two order positions you
look at this rook on c8 danny
that semi-open c file seems more
valuable than the semi-open e
file because the e6 pawn defended by its
friend on f7
the c2 pawn is defended by a bishop but
there are some
loose squares and here comes that knight
potentially to c4 and maybe knight e8 to
d6 first
i feel like it's easier for black to
play this position in part
because it is relatively closed and if
it's a closed positions
knights often outplay bishops
yeah well said uh now what's interesting
is if you go knight c4 lavon is probably
considering just taking that thing off
the board
um although
it's an interesting moment you kind of
had to move the knight because a5 was
under fire so no instead he maintains
the tension he's going to relocate the
bishop to one of these diagonals
also knight to c5 is on the agenda so
probably moving this knight to either d7
or e8 makes sense here
yep indeed he doesn't and d4 is
a problem so you if you play c3 then
instead of having your pawn
safely defended uh with the bishop now
it's on a
potentially vulnerable square so i
really like the way levon is handling
this
and actually i like that move from yan
even though it doesn't threaten anything
this kind of
re-maneuvering of your pieces to
coordinate better bring that rook over
towards the center or the king side
there could be a
you know a g4 type of push in the future
indeed and now you see white's pieces
like they planned it all along joining
the party unfortunately black's position
is so solid that you know
you're still just kind of staring at a
wall here
lavon offers the trade of the darksword
bishops
okay the biggest issue for
white long term is this weak c pawn and
yeah
um
and and nepo do something with the
pressure on the king's side to kind of
distract from that being the main focus
because
notice what devon is doing everybody
he's getting surgical up in this he
trades the bishops
now he's offering the queen trades if
pieces keep coming off the board
it's easy peasy to just focus in on the
weak c pawn and so
kind of an instructive uh approach there
from the armenian right
good good anticipation of of the
technique and and what black really
wants to focus on
yeah because as we were talking earlier
look at
what white's rooks are doing doubled on
a semi-open file
but they're still not doing anything
because e6 is so well defended by a pawn
whereas look at what levon is about to
do double on the c file
and stare right down at the c3 pawn
danny you were just talking about that
i think this position might
strategically be lost for
white and you know i don't mean i don't
know he goes down three games
sorry robertson no i don't like talking
in results oriented
um ways but it just looks so bad for
what at this point it's definitely a two
result position as they say everyone
meaning black
is playing for a win but can only draw
uh if it doesn't work out and white is
really
it's much worse than the computer is
saying this is such a hard position for
white to hold
oh this is such a big moment can you
take on c3 the answer
was the answer i was hoping you would
have the answer
so to the batcave we go analysis let me
at least show the basic tactic if you
take with the knight there's knight to
be one
but wait computer thinks black what
yeah because the work on c8 is defended
so you can play knight a2
oh sick x-ray vision
defending your knight through the enemy
rook
and it only works because of what robert
pointed out that that rook is defended
so he's calculating that being aronian
and he's going to decide whether he can
take here this is such
a huge moment it's winning if he sees it
because of
knight a2 yeah this that was not my
instinct but
you see the eval bar next to the board
it's saying black is fine better after
knight takes c3 it's like
all right so what can it be and he takes
you to the rook on c3 which was my
first question was can i just do this
and the answer is yes
this transition is not going to yield as
much for black i think partly because
after the
the trades happen i think e4 is just
weak
the king comes up quickly oh well now
now it's e4 is just being traded i
thought
he was going to take c2 first yeah what
was that decision
yeah why why didn't he take c2 first
that that was weird
i thought he was going to take here and
take knight takes d6 instead
uh instead of taking back on c2 was
their knight takes d6 ah
maybe but that even that gives black
okay well
obviously now we're in an end game where
things have recovered
for the russian and yawn likely likely
not gonna go down three games
looks like he should hold but knights
can be very tricky in these end games
but look at the time advantage by the
way right like
in another extra minute position for
young
he just can't win the knight's too
strong on d6
up on he's up on the clock a lot yeah
you know it allowed us to be interesting
if we talked to jan after the match
whether he thought that as long as he
was in a game or two he was still the
favorite and bullet we'll find out i
mean right now i don't think he's
thrilled with his situation and i don't
i don't know that i would put him as a
two-game
favorite and bullet maybe one game but
25 minutes we're going to find out what
what what happens when the fastest
portion kicks in
and isn't it funny danny how you look at
these games so far and probably
our audience is like well clearly yan is
the better bullet player he moves much
more quickly
but there are players alexander grishout
being chief among them
who are relatively slow in classical
chess and in
games with slightly longer time controls
but they can really speed up
right and lavon has proven that he is
the type of player he can
be exceptional in bullet even if he
seems to be
we call them time managers robert not
necessarily time takers like they just
made they manage whatever time is being
given to them given that particular
time control right whether it's
classical grishik we know gets the most
out of his time
right he gets under time pressure a lot
five minute and three minute
but in bullet that doesn't mean that
they don't know how to manage their
clock there too by the way here comes a
night check and the eight pawns falling
what's wait but can i get trapped if you
take it oh yeah
take it let's show it let's show it
levon aronian just offered a draw by the
way yawn declined it but it doesn't
matter we're oh no yawn is going for the
win we're still going to show it
if you had taken the pawn king to c2
billy blue the knight runs out of
squares what's funny is black is
probably still not even losing if he
trades but okay
back to the live game a king and pawn
ending and we will
have peace throughout the land the uh
the two game lead maintain now right for
lavon robert
and 25 minutes on the clock exactly
um not going to complain anymore danny
i used to complain that we had too many
berlins i think i've seen enough
french's for the day
you've seen enough french's yeah
well notice that uh jan does acknowledge
defeat in this game at least the meaning
he chose
about opening uh if you're just tuning
in lavon won a very nice game on the
white side of this four bishop d3 french
just
a game or two ago and in that game it
was c5 played
by yon but not here instead we have a
different variation being played
we do black has the bad pawn structure
but the two bishops and you often hear
the bishop pair being advantaged i
prefer having the superior pawn
structure in blitz games in particular i
think
with less time on your clock it's just
easier to play positions with a sound a
stable
structure and look at those pawns right
if e takes d4
going for a trade in comes the knight
directly hitting your c6
pawn and causing you some serious
problems
yep interestingly that you said that
in faster time controls you just prefer
having the strategically easier position
to play which
there are a lot of practical elements
that go into this kind of thing because
sometimes it's a position you're
comfortable with that is most effective
not necessarily
the objectively best line um
bishop a6 now played by yon and
levon's got to be thinking can i get
away with taking that pawn
that's also my question and yan of
course going for
some tactical variations that include
bishop takes c3
as an idea because the knight on e2 is
pinned to this rook on f1 but after d
takes e5 the knight on f6 is also under
attack
so there you go many different
possibilities
i feel like you believe in lavon's
position here
i do yeah i do and it's not just because
john played the french
looks good i mean the transition is
based on like
you wish if you were black that you
could take and the point is the knight
can't take because the rook is hanging
but i think there's just too many pieces
hanging for black right i mean tonight
i literally have calculated zero here
robert my style
minimal work but my instincts tell me
and i tend to follow my heart white's
better
listen to your heart or the eval bar
either way
[Laughter]
yeah no white is definitely doing well
here and you can tell that
in addition to how we're evaluating it
look at the time usage by young yeah
he's saying all the time ben plays
knight to d5
and he's still hoping to make use of
this and frustrating pin
from a6 to f1 but to start with
i think white can play rookie one here
as a move uh
it definitely deserves to be considered
i would also look
at i don't want to play knight takes d5
that just fixes your pawn structure so
even a move like bishop d2 by the way
i mean you you could i think rookie one
just makes the most sense just
get the rook off of the pin no okay
levon's gonna trade
now what
that was something that we didn't like
because because now it's getting harder
to defend the night so what does lavon
have in mind
i was thinking knight f4 but i don't
know how
he works out so well
you're nothing if you're not tricky
silly robert
that is c3 is interesting too because
even if you take the knight you played
rookie one and actually
white is still coming out up just a
little bit ahead of this
is rook d2 or rookie one more precise
i actually don't know if it is but the
point is that once the bishop takes on
c3 here
after b takes c3 that bishop on c1 wants
to go out to
a3 and if that's the case maybe having
the option to double in the d
file is extremely valuable yes
he takes c3 bishop okay he takes there
oh
okay so maybe it didn't matter in the
end
yeah but it was an option you were right
and that was an interesting thing to
cons
i don't even know if you were wrong i
mean if the bishop came there and
somehow prevented castling
it actually had been a tricky little
spot
for the black king
okay so white's gonna have superior pawn
structure
right so white's pawn structure will be
better but black has
tremendous activity along the d i think
that it should offset the worst pawn
structure but in blitz and now lavon
being the one down on the clock
i think that jan has very good chances
to hold this game
agreed tim population us
that's the only place i want to be right
now
you're blushing over there i know
i do love a compliment
uh so jan doing everything he can to
stop
the mobility of white's pawn structure i
think that's smart
and oh i don't love that move so i liked
what he was restricting the pawns
but in some positions that king on f2
will snake to h3 and potentially into g4
so i don't
love pushing all the pawns uh in this
manner but
i think that john has a better grasp of
this position than i do
no but you're you're not i mean that's a
good point looks like they're going to
head for a draw anyway
um indeed they do but we'll bring up the
analysis board as they start their next
game and take a look at it because i
think you were right
in the sense that um you know you
highlighted these pawns were advanced
for one purpose which was to restrict
you're stopping f4 which would support
this pawn
the h5 pawn is is stopping any other
advances by the pawns and as you said
kind of holding the king back of any
potential infiltrations
this was an interesting decision and
risky if lavonne wanted more
i wonder if he couldn't have tried for a
little bit more
um so i don't know i i kind of
trust your instincts i trust that spidey
sense of robert hess
do you think if the match score uh was
not what it is right now that he would
have
played on i wonder right which is that
now we're already getting into that meta
you know
meta strategy talk time of the match
right and the speeches championship is
unique
and that you've got you know we always
call it the shot clock counting down
so levon actually has two advantages
right now one on the scoreboard the
other on the
time oh look i did it i finally cured my
weatherman dyslexia
i pointed to the clock correctly the
first time this feels
so wrong but now i'm into it this is why
weathermen love their job
you know i i have to work on it because
yeah it's for me i did it
for the first time i was gonna dance
alongside you there
let's do it ready like dancing with
ourselves
i don't think that's exactly insane but
but yeah no seriously levon has
you know the advantage of the clock but
but if he's doing that robert and
getting into bullet where you know a lot
of people feel like yawn could be the
guy
it's going to be interesting by the way
nepo back to the weirdness
back to b3 and lavon is matching him
step for step he said you're going to
play some weird stuff
i'm going to push my a pawn and that is
quite typical if you fianchetto you
often want to push your rook pawn
because you directly challenge that pawn
and open up your rook's line
of vision down to harlem night you just
gifted a diamond membership to maybe a
friend of his that's a streamer go to
twitch.tv
harlem night let's throw up that command
there so harlem night
um but anyway yeah uh
thank you uh thank you there for gifting
giving the gift of chess education to a
friend way to go harlem night
danny you're getting so much love in the
chat right now
do it really who'd you pay
it wasn't me so
someone just said danny is so positive
he's forcing me to smile
yeah that's a big compliment the origins
over try to not smile while they're on a
jet ski while they're watching chess tv
try to not smile while you watch me do
this
i mean it's pretty easy for me so you're
asking the wrong person
chess tv
um we're back to the opening we had in
game one by the way this structure
occurred and that bishop was bad looks
like the difference here is that yawn
has actually broken through on the queen
side
let's go to the bat cave and see what
the difference was robert we had this
exact
opening but here lavonne didn't have the
advance of c5 and knight c6 with d4 he
played the a
pawn first which has led to kind of a
very different position right lavon goes
for advancing a4
and now when the structure opens up and
black does get d4
he's not able to keep it there because
white has ways to kind of wiggle out so
i don't think this is as good as the
position lavon got in that first game
yeah it's not it's um more
double edge i would say because in that
other game
the position is very closed and it
remains closed to the very end of the
game
here both sides have more chances which
is what you want if you're you're on the
pumice you want to win some games you're
down two
but you're also creating some problems
very concretely your a4 pawn is isolated
and can be targeted with either adding
more pressure along the a file or bring
your knight
it's one of your knights to attack that
pawn right he commits away from that
idea you were pointing out knight b6 but
you still have what you're saying
the a pawn here so you're right i guess
lavon um you know
maybe doesn't have the bind that he had
in game one i was talking about but it
is more double-edged because a4 and now
a5
is is a bit of a target um
but you know we talked a lot about that
in the first game
now c4 finally opening up the bishop on
h7
yeah that bishop actually looks very
strong right now and if you go knight to
d3
you can capture it which gets rid of the
bishop but that knight is trying to go
to c5
and that looks kind of scary he's going
to put a knight on e5
no great bishop
but that's thematic right you give up
that pawn you eventually take on c6 you
play good night against bishop that
isn't doing as much as you would like or
in fact in this case he's just going
straight for the b-pawn
without taking off that's why i liked my
move bishop b4 i mean i highlighted it
not just because of the apon robert but
it was headed to c3
i think bishop b4 was better than just
taking the pawn right away
hey you're probably right
this this is fine right black is can't
complain
you okay i'm just trying to liquidate
now
bad luck yeah it's a
an equal position that we're going to
get and i if you're yawn you're just
deciding do i take on d6 and then take
on c6 or do i take on c6 and just
trade into an opposite color bishop
position
i don't know you should rely on you for
those questions
i would take on d6 it feels easier to
rate c6 and win d4
yeah talking about shake
jake bake bake bake it
right on d4 although black does get the
outside past pawn and we
should make mention that and black's
king would be a bit safer
well yawn is taking some time that's
something we say every day he decides no
he wants the opposite code bishop ending
uh it's interesting because you know he
is going to get the bishop on d5
protected by a pawn which is not
something black can get right i mean
black could
try to get the bishop on c3 but it's not
as effective as a bishop on d5
poking here so i kind of like yon's
choice
and wow he pushed the d-pawn so early i
i was going to mention that you put a
bishop on c5
you can think about pushing the pawn
that felt
too soon
yeah because he's going to go bishop c5
now and make it harder for you to just
win the d pawn
no oh that's a good move no he wants
more
and actually white has to be careful
here i'd say
yeah because if i get bishop b4 and d2
you're in trouble yeah and that's a
bailout move you're right he just said
yep i'm going to trade c4 for d3
robert's right because let's bring up
the analysis board because we're going
to have a draw now but that was a
in fact we just had a draw offer that's
a really critical moment because if you
don't just bail out
let's say you you know what do you do
like you try to
there's no way to blockade the pawn like
bishop b4 is coming in
so yeah this was this was getting tricky
now we're gonna have a draw
yet well watch out two seconds gotta
move
oh nine to two seconds okay no draw just
yet
and the king on g7 feeling in worse
shape than the uh
king on g2 k92 is very safe right now oh
f7
0.5 he's losing f7 oh he's losing the
game
wow yawn has made something out of
nothing here
and he oh point one he literally made
that move with point one
oh rookie sevens me if you see oh he
finds it
the last time i was doing commentary
with yon and he had mate and one on the
board he missed it
i don't know if you saw that it was the
it was one of the speeches grand prix
there was a queen g8 mate he missed it
and went on to draw the game actually
wow against uh abusa tara if i remember
correctly yeah
yeah danny i watch you pay attention
yeah i do i would you know me i've
always been a decent student
oh man i thought maybe you just watched
the highlights on youtube but i was
going to follow that with except when
i'm watching you because i don't
remember that lecture you said that you
taught me many years ago
hey we all everyone who's been watching
us for years now knows that you darned
well remember that lecture and you're
just pretending so
no i really don't so yeah anyway
you got it to indian lad who won guess
the move over there at chess.com you can
still play remember cash prizes on the
line if you're sitting on the sidelines
of twitch and youtube
get better at chess don't just watch it
go play guess the move
um all right speaking of getting better
at chess
pawn structure look at white's pawn
structure only one pawn island
what's up pawn island you want to see if
there are pawns in
uh the files adjacent to one another
right so white has pawns from the b
through the h file black has two pawn
islands the a and b
pawns and then the d through h pawn so
white's position
is structurally a bit more sound
and you also have taken towards the
center because black is left
if the trait on b5 blacks off the b pawn
and white's
uh kind of furthermost pawn is the c3
pawn so i just want to
talk about those dynamics a little bit i
personally prefer white's position by
quite a significant margin but danny i
feel like maybe i'm overestimating voice
chances
but even if you're not though it's
instructive because i think especially
well now the transition has made it much
more you know balanced right because we
have dynamic weaknesses for both sides
isolated c pawn and isolated b pawn as
you highlighted but what you were saying
is totally true and it sounds
silly for us to go out of our way to
talk about pawn islands or groupings but
at this level
that's exactly what they're looking for
is any sort of long-term weakness they
can gang up on
um and create problems so positional
weaknesses
five-head thing all right
now white is um you know pressing just a
teeny bit right the c
pawn is objectively as weak as the b
pawn they're both isolated
but white's got a little more space the
knight is also tied down to the e pawn
right this is a little bit shaky here
but
we'll see if aronian has a way to
convert can you just take on e5
right away isn't it hanging you laugh at
the discovery of my bishop
well the rook on b8 was hanging at the
end of that so oh
scheizer wait can i say that oh let's go
let's go look at that
you're right oh bloody hell wait can i
say that too
[Laughter]
i feel like if you say curse words of
other languages in english you can get
away with it
yeah the rook is hanging in the end
blimey
oh danny why didn't he take you're right
everybody missed it
besides robert hess no you said the e
the knight has to protect the epoch
i know but i was just talking i was
talking generally superficially i
wouldn't even realize it was actually
hanging
well that's why you know teamwork makes
the dream work
i just got a note not not on camera yet
but i'll let you know yeah i just uh
i'm getting an fcc fine for that one so
for my my drop of multiple curse words
in other languages but you know what i
do with fines right a lot like my
parking tickets
okay you're a good driver you don't
that's true but it was a it was a joke
anyway h5 played um
lavon is pushing for a win for sure
right that was a that was a very alpha
zero-ish
movie
you honestly said movie and you've been
talking as if you're an awesome i know
so queen of d5 is a good move you're
inviting black to trade and fix the
structure and weaken the the e-pawn so
jan runs away instead
yeah and these double h-pawns they look
weak but
perhaps they're not as terrible as i i
thought because the h5 pawn can go to h4
where it's protected by the bishop don't
take on b7
do not do that yeah taking b7 would
allow rook b8
shaking big um and that's not that bad
actually
you can actually sack the queen on b8
you're saying yeah yeah that's funny
that's funny yeah you almost
then you have the past c pawn he almost
could have gone for that
um but now yawn has the e4 pawn
in the queen sights along with the
d-file
right oh that's a good move
i like that move a lot bishop yeah
didn't expect it but i
am applauding it the main principle
everybody is you're just inviting white
to fix your pawn structure right
undouble the h pawns
wait did it happened wow a queen f5
look at that that's like offering an
exchange into an ending where you have
the
outermost past pawn and you have a
bishop against a knight so a really
instructive moment here yeah
and yawn needs to think long and hard
because it's not about
seeing a tactical sequence here it's
about evaluating your chances to hold
the game
if you do in fact take on f5 but i don't
see much of a choice because g5 is
hanging
oh this is great for levon goes for this
opinion but
uh that's that's an instructive setup as
well yawn calculates it
but he can everything comes with tempo
just in time so that he can get the
knight
in kind of a nice spot where by the way
if it gets to d6 or h6
playing for a win i mean i know the c
pawn's strong but
c6 now i'm pushing that thing yeah the
bishop
wow what an inconvenient little little i
almost said something
about the bishop look at what an
inconvenient little you know what
blocking c1 making it super hard for yon
but he does trade it
and c4 yeah very good
that's really important moment because
that king would have
snaked into d5 and into e6 that could
have been a problem
although black does have this h and g
pawn which would have allowed him to
create a pass pawn but this should be
balanced right now rook c7 rook c8 can
force a draw and if levon wants it yeah
i think we'll see peace now and
oh wait no yawn wants more he says
you're under time pressure lev let's
dance
let's dance baby actually g4 checking
team g5 i may have spoken too soon
young can turn the tables yeah rook c4
was such a key instructive moment not
only from a from a defensive standpoint
but as you highlighted now that the rook
has forced the king
back black actually
robert watch out for crazy lines where i
go here and i sack my rook for the pawn
but win anyway
that's very plausible so c7 king takes
f5
i wasn't kidding and he wins on time
oh my gosh and he's as surprised as i
was
not quite suffering from the same
anxiety issues i am but john john was
definitely surprised there
and levon has his just head in his hands
and he's like what are you doing
we're definitely gonna get one more game
here in the three minute portion the
players have not started it yet
but they're deadlocked now they're tight
back
in the heat of that game danny i forgot
about the
match score i forgot about the clock
situation
i was just looking at this very
interesting
and curious ending here but i think you
were right that black actually turned
the tables and yon was bringing his king
in
and that's part of the reason why levon
lost some time it's actually it's just
good for black at this point
yeah and i don't know why the players
aren't starting make sure that
uh they're aware that they should get
going
um
yeah okay um the tide match so
not really advantage for either player
as far as stalling so for those who are
like hey someone's stalling i don't
really know that it makes a difference
at this point
in terms of the total match clock
ticking away above us but um
yeah i mean the final result was because
of the clock robber but you got to give
jan more credit than that right i mean
it actually was
you know had gotten away from lev on the
board
and that idea of the rook coming down
the night maneuvering to f7h like he
calculated that super
quickly it was super super smooth and
paid off
yeah i mean we kind of are a bit harsh
sometimes
on nepo for the way he plays too quickly
in
moments where you're better than this
you don't need to make that mistake
uh we've seen it we saw that several
times the 2019 sinkhole cup in the round
one against vichy
right pretty sure he just blundered
fully at the end of the game in the last
round against anish kiri
yan botched a rook end game where that
he probably should have held
but in all seriousness you know take
that's the bad side of things
the good side of things is he does find
these
moments where he's trying to press for a
win he finds instructive
tech technical ideas very quickly so
gotta you know give jan the credit he
deserves and he's an amazing player
and i really do think that in this
format he has a chance against anybody
but somehow in years past he hasn't been
able to make it to the final
yep well this year as we know he's on
the magnus carlson side of the bracket
um you've got the hikaru nakamura kind
of wesley so side of the bracket on the
other on the other side of things and
not to say that those four guys are are
necessarily the only favorites but
obviously those are the big names and
um or the people that have made it the
furthest in the last couple of years
particularly with nakamura so um anyway
yeah
i'm with you 100 and i think that
sometimes the blessing is also a curse
right you highlighted where yon has
frankly blown games and given away
points because he played too fast but
he's also sometimes just super
impressive like here
he's already up a minute on the clock
and in blitz that's usually an advantage
um
[Laughter]
blood pressure is this we had the same
reaction but
it was like it was like what are you
doing lavon like that's just not a
you know anyway apparently it's all good
everyone all good in the hood
make a trade wait queen f6 queens is a
really good move hitting f3 and hitting
b2 oh we found it yeah
it forces the trade and the knight comes
to e5 and
taking e5 would be lights out everybody
that is a bad idea
don't do it and it's a good lesson
in when pieces are attacking one another
yeah you one side does
capturing first help me or should i
provoke
my opponent to take my piece that's what
lavon has
just said please take building the
tension baby just building the tension
baby
and those double pawns danny is blitz
not enjoying those things well you
highlighted it
let's go to the analysis board because
you made a point a few times right that
the instructive
part of yes objectively maybe this is
okay for white classical chess the g
file's as useful as the double pawns but
in fast time controls
so hard to take on a strategic weakness
and then not make a mistake you're a
human being
and now lavon has just won a pawn
and might be pressing for more for the
rest of the game
yeah he is an option here you can trade
queens i would not do that
when my opponent's king is still quite
weak but he can take on d1 and play a
better ending
i think he needs to move more quickly in
positions like this he plays queen f6
he spent 14 seconds that's not that much
time
all things considered but we have seen
him get down to the waning seconds and
that's where he blunders
or gets outplayed you're right and just
like we've given fair criticism to yon
for playing too fast at times in his
career
um i think that if we're talking about
you know the matches today there's been
a couple games that lavon lost
because of time pressure right whether
he actually lost on time or made a
blunder so
i think it's fair um he needs to speed
up just a little bit
he's not losing this game he's not
losing this game
i'm looking at the position here comes
that rook to h6 h6
i mean you could take on b2 put your
knight on e5 and try to get your knight
to the f3 square
you can play no he's building the
tension i like it he's he's uh
doing what you said right bring pieces
continue to stare down the trade
because the trade only activates your
pieces further i love it
oh man just every piece of his is doing
something useful
and look at look at white's rooks in
particular the rook on b1
it's a purely passive defensive piece
and h
i mean levon is playing a model game
right now
yeah something we learned very early on
as chess players is you never want your
big pieces
defending your little pieces bad sign
and
now even queen e4 you're already up one
pawn head to the end game where e3 is
weak you could
you could just do that and that's why he
took on g3 the h1 was pinned so
an instructive lesson by lavon in pawn
structure creating an
isolated pawn for his opponent and the
light squares we talk about the dynamic
knight against a bishop
if that knight gets to e4 there's
nothing that white can do about it
oh feels so good
the e4 squared just love it all right
how do you get to it nobody's just
taking pawns
greedy man yep
i know you're never supposed to play it
but i do recommend f6 here
oh yeah f6 there would have been
also possible but he goes for checkmate
instead
the h5 pawn was hanging so i guess he
can uh
uh he actually couldn't have captured so
everything looks good at this point and
he's ahead on the clock
so the time's up by the way is the last
three mini game
yeah officially regardless of the result
we will be in bullet after this game
and will it be a one game lead for
aronian or or are we shocked by a
blunder we'll find out
but yeah yawn came back he was he was
down by two
in the match and
but yeah look at look at this this is
great technique i love rook g4
but i said this is a model game like i
understand that
jan didn't play the opening very well he
made a mistake but
it feels like every single move that
lavon has played has had purpose
and he's just gonna win this game and
take a lead into the bullet
i think john maybe played that for the
shot of some tactic with the bishop and
brooke but he maybe forgot about d1
check so
either way he's still in big trouble um
lavon not allowing any kind of counter
play
you have to find some other way to
defend the g pawn i think f6 is in d4
what d4 was also good because of the d4
was also good
e1 square
oh gosh now you get stop
even knight g4 so you can threaten
rookie one oh or the battery
or the battery
yeah make it stop all the light squares
knight f3 check
take on e1 how many extra pounds do you
have
the answer is enough
even nice g1 if you have a king d1 queen
h1 check
and here's knight takes b3
he's gonna gobble the g pawn unless yon
throws in the towel which he does so
on that note wow we predicted a close
match
everybody there's a reason the smarter
chess prediction had this as close to a
50 50 toss-up as we ever get
and robert i mean are you excited for
the bullet here i don't want to go to
break because i just want to talk about
this with you
well before we do go to break danny i
just don't know which lavonna ronin
we'll see we'll see if the
player who is a little bit too
deliberate for his own good where we see
the yon napaneshi who comes out blazing
with sharp lines
i have no idea so danny you excited
we see danny wrench win his second
primetime smackdown taking on john
bartholomew if you haven't subscribed
with your twitch prime now officially a
you problem
you can also do a regular subscription
uh no but we do really appreciate the
support to you and all of our premium
members thanks
thanks for it you make this happen enjoy
the prime time smackdown
at the break the rest of you enjoy a
commercial about a video game that i'm
never going to buy my
kids we'll be right back
[Music]
all right here we go hey i'm not going
to be ashamed of a sweep because i've
already been swept twice in these
matches you shouldn't be
all right let's go okay
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna go for your
tory oh wait no you switched to the
london switching it up
classic sean
anyway yeah it's
i feel like i've been here before so
yeah this strangely looks like the first
game
yeah oh darn it that was a that was a
not
good approach by me um okay that's
painful
yep pain
pain
okay you're giving me that i'm gonna
take the foursquare
got two okay
yes take that square if possible
all right i guess a draw doesn't get me
to win
you know obscure bishops that all drawn
but technically
you still have room to come back in a
draw scenario not that that's gonna
happen
okay okay
i'll take the d file uh-oh
you're playing very fast okay you've
woken up this is scary
i evidently missed my coffee today john
has woken up
and i have to be careful of my clock
again
no okay
try to gather that little pawn there let
my queen
into d2 let her in
oh
this did not go well
free move town population dan i trapped
that night yet
oh crap
okay all right okay i clearly poked the
bear
all right don't be but you're wearing
that grizzly adam shirt where are you
going right after this
this is a branding thing at this point
like this is like you're going hunting
for dance
exactly
okay forgot to take the wrapper off this
show is not brought to you by nestle
pure life
although it is my preferred brand of
bottled water okay
okay this is it i i've you've got game
five written all over your face and i'll
give you a chance at the scandi to get
there let's do it
if i win i want it to be in your home
turf oh
but not this line i hate this line oh
mine
i thought you would like this one oh
this is so
irritating this can be fun
okay okay
uh i don't know what i'm saying i give
you credit because usually you avoid
this candy against me
i do and so you know this is a
it's uh playing with some guts dan
yep um gotta respect that gotta respect
that um what are we doing here
i guess i'm gonna do this all right i'm
gonna
no i don't want to give you that i like
the dark squares
okay what i'd like to do here
don't even know
yeah there we go this is some intense uh
positional maneuvering yeah no i've been
uh
learning from a positional master her
name's beth harmon
ah i've heard of her
i forgot my knight was pinned that was
adorable of me i tried to play knight c5
um what are you doing here that was
probably a bad move by me
what am i doing oh no oh no this is the
money i'm using
this is the danny we know and love
okay okay what happened there
i'm gonna let my time run out that was
going well for me i should have played
a3 i guess on b5 i should have slowed
down your little
your little minority yeah that probably
would have been a better idea i agree
you're so smooth sometimes
so
[Music]
and yet again we have a snapshot of our
top guessers
playing against the move dragon b70 this
was the last game of the three minute
portion so
a couple of random games chosen
still dragon b70 sitting there at the
top robert as he usually does but we'll
see when when it's all said and done who
ends up taking on the cash prizes
just like we'll see when it's all said
and done just how accurate these smarter
chess predictions were
if uh if they are guess what we have
robert we have overtime chess
that's true because yonder palm she
predicted to be a
one game favorite in the bullet portion
levon aronian thanks to this final
victory
in the 3-1 segment has the lead
what do you think danny is it going to
be accurate all jokes about smarter
chess aside
i honestly i would love overtime chess
you know you know how i feel
you know um anything that keeps me away
from
anything that keeps me away from you is
a bad thing i want this show to last
forever
uh forever is a long time and i think
you'll eat those words
but i mean i'm with you i think that you
know especially
you just gave us one of those moments
where someone says i love you and the
other person goes
hey i started off i just said i love you
and you didn't say i love you back
i started off the show with like an
endearing statement and you kind of
brush it aside so
that was you getting back at me no two
wrongs don't make a right
okay two wrongs don't make it right just
ask beyonce
all right it's time for the bullet to
begin
yeah better start otherwise i'm leaving
all right here we go
[Laughter]
hey we have a sicilian again yeah
back to that allopin yes
and lavon quick in the opening stage of
the game going for this b4 line
not so fast that's why a5 was played
whoa
yeah i wonder if jan took a peek at this
at all but he def
definitely has a little bit of a better
start than he did previously
here comes the busted open center that
should favor
the bishop on g7 if we talk about
specific pieces because
that wants the diagonal to open up but
maybe not so fast knight c6 knight e4
both sides have weak pawns that they
have to figure out here
indeed d4 b2 versus c6 and maybe
a5 um yellen offers a trade straight up
of c for b and now
queen d2 i would play just to protect b2
give my rook access to d once what he
says i'm taking c6
i'm with you i felt like lavon should
have sat a little bit on that but he
goes for some activity instead
well i think that black's pawn structure
is stuck in place or the e4 pawn in
particular whereas that d-pawn
may quickly rush itself to d6 in which
case not only is the f7 square problem
because the bishop on c4 is so strong
but there's a past pawn that you have to
deal with
and okay d5 very tempting here
there's bishop d5 huh going around for
the pawn so danny i mean i like white's
position i think he's doing everything
you could ask for in a bullet game
and a5 is weak so queen a4 was played
yeah i agree he's also playing quickly
yawn's supposed to be the faster player
but
not so fast as aronian
and the rook can drop like the c1 that's
important yeah the queen comes back
or the rook they're both possible
uh and rook c1 is queen d3 check that's
why he drops the queen back
queen d3 still happens and down goes a3
gives up the a pawn but he's still a
little bit better as long as the king
doesn't get in trouble look at look at
that move
g4 love it
i was looking at bishop f7 check and
queen c4 but i think that there's bishop
king f7 bishop e6
within his book c7 check no that works
oh he goes for it
yeah if if rook takes the bishop hangs
everybody if king takes queen c4
bishop c4 thank you you're to thank
everything that you don't lose your game
there
thank god for that bishop c4
and now white's just up and pawn king g2
play h3 even if the rook comes to three
you fly queen c2
yep he's doing it playing all the moves
as i highlight him
and here comes rook c7 i guess and yeah
black can't move
well i can't move you can bring the
queen to c6 here comes the d-pawn at
long-last bishop d4
anybody yep oh bishop d4 there's no way
you sell this you can trade everything
and e4 falls in the end he takes takes
yep everything and white's gonna be up
there goes that passer queen c3 check
wins the check picks it up
and then there's rook f727 just to uh
end the game that's a check
i was like wait what's that always check
it might be mate
and there you go levon aronian takes the
first
bullet game and we are going to have
a photo finish here i mean if yawn does
prove to be the better bullet player
he's going to have to
he's gonna have to do it uphill right
now down two games
with 26 minutes left in the total clock
can you say tiebreaker can you say
overtime
i can't say overtime i'm just not sure
we're going to get it but
danny what's interesting about this is
you and i and smarter chess predictions
all thought that hey jan is the better
bull player between these two but that
increment really helps of course
and look at lavon's rating i might add
yep
wait but we saw the rating okay the
ratings studied
sorry john studied this position because
we had this as a possibility in like the
like first or third or whatever game of
the match and he just changed the move
order and gave up his dark square bishop
so jan studied this at some point
so he improved on his earlier game
although i like yon's position better
right so that's something john improved
on his uh or your game from
this match oh i thought you were saying
lavonne you lavon stuff i just missed
who you
studied yeah yeah yeah i was gonna say i
love white's position now
so uh he he definitely looked at this
during one without remember this this is
the
second bullet game i'll try to remember
to ask that question i mean now knight
c7 is crushing oh rookie 58.
boomtown it's over look at john
he's uh he's a happy camper over there
this is a
for making it tricky he's still still
busted and if you okay like bishop takes
c6 even it just destroyed the pawns
oh yeah you could you could probably
enter an end game with knight against
bishop at some point as well
yeah other bishop c6 oh
rook d6 is bishop f7 oh gosh
wow you weren't wrong though i wonder if
you could have just traded on c6 taking
d8 gone to the end game and the knight
was winning over the bishop but don
didn't go for it
well he might go over the check now yeah
rookie eight at the end
yeah rookie it now too rookie eight
takes quincy said he takes takes and
then
then you win up six at the night look at
those dancing heads by the way that
tells you we've had a back and forth
match
and uh that the underdog
by a very very small percentage 46 to 54
percent i think lavonne
is back on top
now you take c6 and win the king of pawn
no you just take f7 oh
i'm not sure i love this um and the
reason why
is you look where the extra pawn is it's
on the king's side h8 square dark square
it's not easy to make progress here yeah
plus black is already in a great
position blockading with a centralized
knight
holding all the squares yeah b6 put all
your oh he's gonna b4 okay
yeah he wants b4 but the king is coming
to e4
96 that says not so fast d6 holds the
square
push it baby no
yeah i feel like jan should have had
more yeah john should have
john was winning i mean at one point
here for sure
and how to do this a b4 so knight f593
here comes
wait a second oh this is no good john
just took a peek over at the clock i'm
sure but that was what his uh
his eyes were there and his face is like
not happy i mean the thing is is is the
knight
okay he's giving up c2 to go king d5 and
win c5
yeah but he's better now right you have
to move
f5 okay this is so tough made it with
1.9 seconds
now this is winning for white right wow
six one point one second you gotta move
oh point two literally living on the
increment
point one yeah this is crazy bishop four
traps the knight
the knight gets trapped oh my gosh
then i can go to ccp
no because you got the c2 square yeah
oh but that's why he reordered the
bishop now he's pushing the a pawn but
now you can play tickle 91 knight back
okay king b7 a6 a7 this is just nuts
wait king might get trapped now
all right so knight so crazy yeah
because the knight forces bishop b5
guard to the g6 square
he's ready to get out he gets out king
b5 and he's going to win yeah now he's
winning for sure
oh my god somehow lost whatever the
thread was that the knight had over the
bishop and now yawn should be able to
convert this
yeah the knight can't stay there forever
yeah down goes somebody's
trap pony and with it
oh man well from a match
strategy point of view um
you know every game that lasts a long
time i guess is still a favor you know a
good game for lavon but you know
this is close enough that you can't even
really say that right at this point
neither side is really thinking about
the clock it's a one game
match with 20 minutes to play that was
not the cleanest victory for john robert
but he did get it done
he did you know when it his back was
against the wall and he could not really
he can't afford to not win games because
there's still plenty of time left 21
minutes
but he really needed that for his
confidence if nothing else
we have another interesting position
where black has these
pawns in the fifth rank are they
strengths because you can keep pushing
the four they're restricting white's
pieces
are they weaknesses because after bishop
f1 knight c4 type of moves
those pawns can quickly get under attack
yeah
notice how i highlighted them green when
you said strengths and then i switched
to red when you said weakness
um you know you are as long as you know
that i'm also contributing to the show
that was all you're you're the best
commentator in your dream
thank you i love you you just uh no but
i will highlight for your ideas
anytime baby you can be my wingman i'll
be yours
um all right e5 is a target you're right
and
queen to b3 might make it trickier for
black because i'm gonna bet on these
pawns becoming
not strengths but weaknesses
you know when when you said you can be i
thought were gonna say you can be my
bodyguard
i could be your long-lost pal but i'll
be
your chest coast toaster no no different
song
that's okay yeah
all right by the way they did prove to
be weaknesses lavon picked them apart
and uh what's something you got a couple
miners for the rook
but i like white with the open king
uh yeah i agree oh okay so what's
what is the actual count it's two minus
miners
for a rookie pond three pawns three
points
yeah so rookie one knight e5 can come
next i would
probably advise to trade some pieces oh
but c4 is hanging
oh it does anyway so
queen c4
looks possible he decides to go watch
out for those light squares danny right
that could be
a quick counter it'll get baited
that's that's great advice
so queen a7 is happening next that's
such an important pawn to lose
yeah the outside passer could win the
game in the end
rook d1 maybe then h a4 a5 then
just push that black is like a stuck i
mean
you're pinned down to d7 so we're by the
way he was just inviting bishop e5 which
would have been a blunder rook d7
nice now pushing did win the c pawn
which gives him bishop d4 as a
possibility
okay so he's gonna pull the heat and
then can he take on h6 can you just go
for that pawn
wait he's really gonna take a draw and
jan says no
dawn says no i'm surprised by that
i'm sh now now the bishops are dominant
queen of four
lavon is getting nervous under time
pressure that was
the first time said that all day where
lavon just i mean that was like
clearly a dubious approach there and
he was better but didn't didn't uh he
was nervous about his clock
and now he's now he's gonna lose the end
game we're gonna have a tight match he's
in such big trouble because of the
presence of the sea
pawns if those pawns are on the board
actually he's getting the pawn
okay now now you can find a way to get
this pawn
he got it and that makes it easier
because look at the h6 pawn
look at the color corner you need to
give up that rook for the light square
bishop so
once you take the pawn on c5 bring your
king all the way back
towards the h file and you can give up
your rook all you gotta do is zack this
guy for this guy
yeah or you can try to win this game
maybe that c pawn is gonna win him the
game
stranger things have happened okay rook
c3 no
he doesn't put the rook behind the pawn
wait this is actually getting really
worrisome for young
yeah this is the bishops are supposed to
be better than the brook here but i have
no idea what's going on oh my gosh i
think he's in big trouble i think he's
losing this game
rook g8 and then c7 d7 thank you
and the f pawn pushes f4
wow what a turnaround wow
so much for me calling the tide match
joshua chamberlain lives i jinxed it
i forgot about you remember that guy who
hated me
whatever happened to joshua i bet joshua
chamberlain exists in the chat just
under a different name
if you're out there joshua chamberlain
show yourself
we're gonna see king g3 h2 for oh he's
so sick
h2 you bring the rook over he's going to
get a knight
no he's made it oh i thought but even
even if he gets tonight he's still
losing
yes well we'll bring up the analysis
board real quick i missed it the timing
but that's still an instructive tactic
because white is winning in these end
games everybody even if you're down a
tempo
like if if black was to move here the
queen gets mated
the black's only move is to get a knight
and then you play king f3
and it's still a winning end game for
white because uh the the king and knight
gets separated and it's a force win
so anyway lavon wins it's a two-game
lead joshua chamberlain strikes back
that's what i keep thinking about how
many people here remember joshua's
chamber
if you're out there you actually know
the inside joke i mean i just
go up even more
y'all but you didn't finish the early
days of of of
of chess success on twitch
somebody didn't like me that i ever said
anything apparently and if i ever said
like oh this guy's gonna win
he really was like belaboring the point
so we had to mute him in banana and we
kicked him wherever you're out there
joshua chamberlain
turns out you were right joshua
chamberlain i do jinx players
so this position is very good for yon
because look at his the place from his
pieces
he has the d5 square under his control
look at the night seat on c6 dominated
by a pawn three squares away
and that's very important you want to
look at how your pieces can start
uh going forward and getting aggressive
and that's exactly what jan's doing
pushing his pawns at the king side
taking over central squares and levon's
actually not doing so poorly to reroute
his pieces knight to e6 give me the f4
square
but white is clearly ahead ooh nice oh
wait apparently it's not a good tactic
it looks good to me
wait is the queen getting trapped or g
takes the knight of four the queen gets
trapped in f6
whoa whoa
whoa i know kung fu
wait actually where's that queen going
yeah how's he getting out
it's knight f5 knight f5 holds oh he
didn't
no knife is rook a6 oh wow the queen's
getting trapped in more ways than
one that's no fun um
so bishop g7 queen h4 the queen gets to
escape
bishop e7 queen takes e5 the queen
escapes for now well this is a crazy
wild position lavon has no time to
figure it out
no he really does but if we see the eval
bar we know there's some way for black
to do this but with no time there's just
i
i'm gonna guess yan gets away with
stealing every single pawn the queen
just did and lives to tell about it
wow i mean queen c4 only move
you could go to b6 but then there's like
92 and
right knight takes c3 happens there oh
well now there's 92 tanks and g4 is
hanging
whoa oh he's going for the attack right
away and watch out for rook takes e3
ideas with queen g4 to follow
oh yeah okay this is getting
very tense spicy
rook 63 no jason g4
yeah rookie three he had it
he made my voice go high nobody does
that nobody makes me bleed my own blood
he still has so much pressure though the
93 is stuck here
seriously black still black still has a
ton of pressure but with no time on the
clock i'm going to guess that he missed
his chance with brook takes e3
what's the material count blackstone
pawn
one yeah yeah and now you have queen e6
at the end of some lines if you want
raid here comes queen e6
okay i mean you go to the end game if
you're into it but no
buy once more so what's we need eight
and then rook g3 no richie's already
wouldn't work
was that king upon ending winning i
don't know
he misses me
oh my god my name is queen takes g3
oh my god multiple wins missed
only takes f2 as me wait
what is happening here who's gonna win
queen d5 check
and it's in blacks winning levon is up a
pawn
oh my god
what just happened oh jeez
louise what did louise ever do to you
danny i know right pushing my blood
pressure up
now it's definitely
now lebron is somehow winning this game
oh my god they've got time too it's like
somebody needs to remind them
slow down boys
[Laughter]
you've got some time on the old tickety
rook c4
end the game i can't my voice
okay black is still gonna win and this
is this could be a back breaker for
yon oh my gosh he's shaking his head
because that was one that
oh that's one that's going to make the
uh end of the month twitch clip
highlights real to the analysis board we
go let's just at least show that there
was a mate
for those of you who didn't exactly
catch why we were freaking out because
right here
queen to d3 was checkmate
and then queen takes g3 was winning
and at some point i think yawn was
almost winning again oh my god all right
back to the next game
oh man wowser was fun
hey i i didn't know how much i missed it
until now that i'm here i realized just
the adrenaline rush so much fun watching
these games come down to the last moment
this is there's a lot on the line here
these are thousands of dollars
uh on the line in these chess games and
uh this game's over
john's getting crushed look at him he's
just john's falling apart
falling apart at the tilt the tilt is to
resign
and then just win the next game i know
that's asking a lot but he has over 10
minutes left that is yeah my problem is
he could lose another two full minutes
on the clock and lose this game anyway
right so from a match strat
pov is the k i'm gonna try to speak how
the kids would say
i am matt strat pov af
as af sometimes people say as af which
doesn't make any sense by the way
yeah yeah you're you're as a fool i get
it but please don't
that's what it means right as a fool oh
my gosh
i i was just saying how much i was
enjoying it
now i really like all right yeah this is
tough
lavon needs to uh i mean john needs to
throw in the towel here this is
going to be yes chances are the hole i
feel like
no no i should resign
but it's too late right now it's too
late to go back
too late to apologize yeah well that was
that's been true for a long time now wow
i have nothing to say anymore i don't
have anything to say either
but thank you to mary 1918 who just
gifted a membership to someone
you gave the gift of chess education
there's a lot of people doing that
around the holidays
that was well done nice
all right no but seriously i think this
is almost i i did not think we were
going to be in a position to call the
match
at all in this in this match and it's
still there's plenty of time but we are
now
under 10 minutes and yawn is
really i mean it was it was a three-game
swing that last game i mean it was it
was insane
uh but lavon is seven seconds so
you know okay there you go yeah now
quite yet although i'm with you i'm with
you
84 all right rook f3 let's go let's go
the problem is he's down two full pawns
okay you're down two pawns here comes
queen d5
force the ladies off the board might be
the smartest thing levon ever did
making john think he has chances to win
this game
because it's it's look at that look at
that clock oh wait
okay but there might be that kane knife
six check comes ouch knight f6 chick is
rover
over billy blue resign resign yawn while
you still can
and 97 yeah
i'm it's every game from here on out
must be
one every game must be one
and pretty quickly at that because you
have just under eight minutes
and even if there were no increment
that's two minutes per game this
you gotta get this one yawn and you
gotta look i'm sure
you're going to whatever and dan the
dyslexic weatherman
i messed it up this time yeah you gotta
you gotta go that way
i had it right you gotta poke it up
um yeah this is uh
this is i think we've gone full tilt and
and i think that uh lavon has survived
the storm i mean
already looking like a good position for
black again up a clean pawn
yeah you know white would like to
unleash some sort of attack but that
bishop on c8 may just land on g6 and
say what next
so silent between us right now what do
you say
it's so silent between us right now i
just don't i just don't know what to say
our relationship is is beyond words the
smile on your face robert lets me know
that you need me
oh my gosh there's a look in your eyes
are you telling me that i say it best
when i say nothing at all
right you and i could talk or not talk
for hours
boo oh we need to check oh gosh
if the knight moves you take with check
so there's no mates
no attacks and this is an owie an
owie for yon and with him
i think uh i think an owie and his
speech has championship chances
yeah this is uh it's already we go up by
five games with only five minutes left
we can officially call it so
either a blunder heard round the world
or we're looking at a surprising result
i guess i mean for lavonna rhonian
i mean not i mean we said this was 50 50
and i and i said i had no idea was going
to win this match and
voted our stats but i guess i thought it
would be close
all the way down to the finish and this
is this is surprising
can i just make a quick comment danny do
you mind of course
so uh smarter chess remember what you
said about the bullet portion of this
match
[Laughter]
do you remember that let me go to chat
and back up my boy robert
yeah that what's martyr jess
was it like plus two for yon and bullet
according to smart chess predictions
so just throwing that out there
yeah well lavonne doesn't play enough
oh okay she's broken she wants me
that was a sound effect if only our eval
bar had sound effects
you so clear i just discovered a new
trick
every time i pull my ear i go whoa look
at that
and we still haven't exactly wait we we
still
possibly have a match if young wins the
next too quickly yawn has got to win
every game from here on out
but he's still down by three as pretty
as that was
levon would have to lose and lose
quickly
right and that was smarter chess
pulling some strings behind the scenes
after i started talking some smack he
doesn't want it to look so bad on his
stat sheet
yeah that was
i don't know how that happened but
anyway lavon right now still with
a three-game lead but he's spending
quite a bit of time
jan's getting what he needs he he needs
to win and he's a win fast and
the first step is playing fast
one game at a time and i guess you know
not that it
not that's the most critical thing on
their mind but every win right now is
still worth
cash right with the format of the event
so keep keep winning games john you
never know just keep swimming
finding nippo just keep swimming just
keep swimming
um oh oh negative two would be made but
because i play king of seven
knight f2 is is a main on the board
that's a threat
it is and bishop g3 in some version
could be a threat too or pawn g3
pawn g3 right now g3 g3
go for f2 open up g4 ah
oh but there's f3 i guess i was trying
to break this position open
yeah g3 is a real threat though
and look at levon down to 10 seconds
he's using his time wisely because every
second off the match clock gets him
closer to a match victory
but we're still in striking distance
here knight
pawn g3 we got mate on the next move oh
the bishop goes back to g1 so it's not
me oh he gets out
but h4 h3 has to be something yeah also
the bishop coming in
h3 wait i just got out of this
oh my gosh and he's wasting precious
seconds at the very least even if he
lavon loses his game the time that's
getting off the clock is so important
even if he loses he defended perfectly
to uh
take more time off the clock by the way
look at john's time
he needs he needs to win this actually
he's
if he doesn't win now they're not gonna
have enough time remaining
yep anyone okay lavon loses on time
takes more precious seconds off the
clock
i mean this is a bit like
jim carrey talking to mary swanson dumb
and dumber you're saying there's a
chance
right saying there's a chance i think
you need new jim carrey references
have i used that one more than enough
yeah yeah we gotta retire that one
don't be sad don't be sad i'm sorry okay
by the way yawn is a scotch expert and
doesn't play it often against his
uh his elite super grand master peers
these days but it is it is something he
knows well
only a minute 39 on the clock i mean it
is
possible all they have to do is start
the last game
so yawn has to win this game
and then start the last game before time
is up
right and that's why yon is moving so
quickly which can backfire over the
board
but he needs to do this he has no other
choice and well he's going to bishop f5
next
and it could be a bit scary for that
king but for now
there are plenty of black pieces there
are not enough white attackers
oh my gosh you're really looking at that
time a minute
oh a minute ticking down
lavon lavon's just gonna win the match
on the clock
all he has to do is get himself in a
position where he can let the time tick
down
yon dug himself too big of a hole it
looks like
um look at this hg5ht5 please open up
the h file i want to meet you in the
next
30 seconds he's using his time letting
it tick down 15 seconds
i wonder how up to date they are though
right because
uh the players do they know exactly the
amount of seconds remaining
they share the same global clock but
isn't even the production clock they
have the official clock
on whatever on their they have it we
share it with them
i don't know how closely they keep it in
front of them but
um i think officially at this point
unless there's a win on the board for
white in the next 10 seconds
we have a victor in the match and that's
going to be lavon ironian
yeah it looks like he's winning over the
board as well he's up a full piece
bishop to h6 closes the h file
it looks like lavon has made it through
that's it
just like that speed chess championship
round of 16 drama continues here
lavon ironian defeats yon dupont machine
regardless of the result of the final
game
it goes lavon's way as is poetic it
would seem
and robert levon aronian
pulls off the upset albeit a very very
close match
this was the eight nine matchup in the
bracket so really hard to call it an
upset
it was it was predicted as a borderline
coin flip and levonaroni and gets it
done
yeah it was predicted 56 in yan's favor
and that came down to the bullet but
because levon had the lead going into
the bullet
and was playing really well in the
opening games young could never
quite find a in road to take the
match control away from lavon ronin
congratulations to
the armenian number one he played an
excellent match yeah
wow incredible stuff he gets to face his
friend in the next round in maxine
vashey the grab but we will be back with
final moments we leave you with the
final moments of my best of five match
that went down between john bartholomew
and i for those
subscribers to the twitch channel and
all of our supporters we really
appreciate it here's our
game five of primetime smackdown and
when we return final moments of today's
scc battle
[Music]
all right hey you didn't get all dressed
up for nothing
you're welcome for having a game five i
i liked the shirt
but now thank you it's only fitting we
haven't we haven't played for a while so
yeah i think the people want us
i think the people are happier this way
what happens in the event of a draw
we play again um let's just do that and
split the money
what do you think that's fine by me
you're like you know whatever i don't
even know what's going on here all right
here we go
um i sent you a rematch here we go
you're gonna go for your silly you're
going to do it you're doing your
okay i'm going to play boring chess i
got to mix it up
i almost played the blumenfeld and then
decided
decided no
okay really
okay okay
okay
oh my god this is just terrible
terrible all right
uh we'll go there
uh i'll take that
what would russian school boys do here
every russian schoolboy knows everyone
schoolboy knows you just repeat
oh
i'm so bad it always happens this way
this goes fast too
bestified bullet i'm like the face of
someone who choked in life
that's what i am this is kind of like
your adopted danny matches
but a little bit different i mean yeah
like i saw that draw you got against a
niche geary i think it was it felt
really good actually to get that draw
and you're done it feels even better
that i know that you watch yeah
for sure all right well
congratulations thank you whatever
moving on
[Music]
now you've deadlocked things and your
pawns are also very weak
i agree king d7
and he missed it oh and
i don't know what john said but it
wasn't pg
oh man and again he's just shaking his
head
oh wow that was painful
and we are back here with the final
moments of today's speeches championship
match lavon aronian takes down
john dupont michie if you couldn't tell
from that moment of the match today we
will actually not have interviews with
either player today
uh and robin and i will give you our
final thoughts and preview the upcoming
matches
here in uh here for the next next 5-10
minutes or so
on that note robert so again this was uh
not not a surprising victory in any way
the stats said it was going to be close
but i think the way it
ended definitely surprised some of it
was that one critical bullet game
right that john lost that was the
backbreaker
yeah truthfully it did feel like lavon
had the upper hand
i would say the majority of the time in
this match of course
jan had some games where he played
really excellent chess
i i think the winner was the player who
did
play better throughout i think that jan
was probably going to be upset with
himself it's
how the bullet went you're absolutely
right danny he should have had a chance
there he was only down
one game from remember correctly heading
into the bullet and yet
lavonne was the player who seems
stronger of the two so i don't know if
you agree with me but i do believe
that jan will be upset but lavon is the
deserted victor in the match
i agree i mean from start to finish uh
he also he also was leading most of the
match start to finish right
after jumping out to a two and a half
one and a half lead he maintained that
lead
all the way until yon tied it at eight
eight before the last game of the three
minute portion so
you know usually the person who's
leading throughout was also i mean
sometimes they lead and
and it never gets tied again right but
but it definitely a sign that lavon felt
in control of the match
um and uh in the bullet he surprised the
smarter chess stats
right along with maybe people who
thought nepo would be the the faster
player in the 1-1 segment
and he takes the match victory shout out
again to all of our subscribers and our
gifted memberships coming in here over
the last few moments we hope you
hope you enjoyed the match and we do
appreciate your support
speaking of other matches we've got one
coming up tomorrow for the first time
this year we have a back-to-back affair
ikara nakamura the number one seed the
man at the top
takes on hike marty rosian obviously we
know that hayek is super talented
super talented young player also from
armenia lavon
aronian's countrymen the victor of today
certainly there's not much to say other
than hikora nakamura is the number one
seed for a reason robert and a heavy
favorite
but your quick thoughts on the things
you're looking forward to tomorrow
yeah i think that hikaru is
in everybody's mind the from pretty much
the winner before the match even begins
i don't think
that hikaru necessarily feels that way
he has great respect for hike marching
roasting who's a phenomenal player
but he's not there yet he's not quite at
the tippy top
the upper echelon the elite level that
is
required to face off against a car in
such a long match
but hype will outplay icaru in segments
he will have some better games but
ultimately yeah hikaru is almost
certainly going to win that match
yep it would be it would be the shocker
heard around the world right
uh for sure but we'll see what hike can
put up as far as as far as uh the fight
goes and i'm sure we'll have a lot of
interesting moments
regardless uh we also have one more
match-up after that i'm sorry no two
we have november 15th and november 16th
a circle on your calendar duda versus
caruana
and artemia versus geary uh you know
i think we could argue that after the
nakamura mardi rossium match
both those other matches are our total
coin flips robert they certainly are
young christoph duda the stronger of the
two players you know between himself and
five minute quran
in the online sphere but fabinho caruana
is the number two player in the world he
took magnus carlsen to the tie breaks
of the 2018 world chess championship and
on the other
side of the bracket artemyev the speed
demon we've seen him beat hikaru
in speed chess championship grand prix
and title tuesdays
we know how strong he is fully capable
of taking out anish giri who is the
lower
seed so giri despite having a higher
classical rating and
being one of the more talkative players
of the bunch
he has his work cut out for him and you
know that magnus would
he would enjoy beating a niche in a
head-to-head matchup
we see the chat saying they'd love to
have an anish versus magnus
quarterfinals i think a lot of people
would i mean magnus carlson interviewed
after his match victory over parham monk
sulu said he thought that
art or tamiya was the favorite and anish
had some fun
trolling and going back and forth about
that i don't i don't think magnus even
meant it as a slight or even being
sarcastic i think he does see artemium
as the favorite in a blitz match
even if anish geary is the stronger
classical player but either way i do
think it's a 7-10
seed for a reason meaning it's it's
pretty close to a coin flip
um and uh in increment time controls
which you rarely
see when these guys are just playing
casual blitz and bullet
you know a lot of times a stronger
player does win out so we'll see what a
niche can do
um and then as you already said duda and
caruana i i don't that to me feels as
much a toss-up as the one we had today i
have no idea
who's going to win that one fabiano's
working on his blitz all the time
um and jan christoph duda is still the
higher seed for a reason
all right we also had a lot of people
playing guess the move and in the end
random game chosen gives and rewards
indian lad look at that
grand master indian lad taking home the
cash prize shocking
dragon b70 i guess um but uh we know
that he
he makes a regular habit of taking
taking home cash every sec match so
congratulations to indian lad
as well as our two basic level
membership
members who upgraded themselves to
premium by playing guess the move today
nick moyes and cn riddle buying riddle
is that like super cyan i don't think so
you know you know what it feels like
dragon
b70 was taking a food break like went to
make himself a sandwich
and then that was the game chosen and
that was the game shows all the time
because the fact that he's not in the
top three there is also shocking
right um normally and maybe it was that
weird french game where they played the
poison pawn and nobody could guess the
moves
like or maybe it was that bullet game
where they missed checkmate so
you know the fans were saying hey
there's check minute one that's gotta be
the move
but it wasn't played or or poor guessers
when you're guessing better than super
grand masters
you can't be too upset um all right well
this has been
it's been a lot of fun we apologize to
the fans for for no interviews
not that not the normal run of show to
speak production here but
we had a great day regardless it was a
super fun match and we have
a great one ahead tomorrow with ikara
nakamura taking on hike marty rossian so
uh make sure you tune in then we will
see you all for my partner
the one and only mr chess grandmaster
robert hess
the team working hard here all of all of
those who make these events amazing our
moderators and our staff working hard
behind the scenes we appreciate you
and we will see you tomorrow for another
speed chess championship match
until then good night everybody
[Music]
you